[Music]
all right follow yes sir so nice to have
you here it is a pleasure and this has
been in the works for me at least in my
own head since I want to say 2018 2019
wow and then this pesky thing that we
now called Co came along and disrupted
all sorts of plans but finally here we
are so thank you for making the trip and
I'm glad that you are here in person so
we may get a chance to stand up it's
nice that it's in person versus virtual
there's so many more possibilities I
guess so many more possibilities let's
start so people might assume
that right out of the gate maybe as a
fetus but certainly once you entered the
world you had the dexterity of a demigod
and were basically faded to become
someone famous for how they use their
hands is that the case no no no quite
the opposite I think almost as opposite
as it could be on that this is a story
I've been told mhm that once upon a time
my father who was legally blind had
decided to become a minister went to
seminer in Enid Oklahoma and was walking
down the streets from seminer
but he had moved into this kind of rough
neighborhood was trying to witness and
these two teenagers decided to try to
steal from him he didn't know what they
were up to but then when they realized
he was blind they decided not to hustle
him but instead they tried to guide him
to where the bus was and encourag him to
go to another area and he invited them
to his church invited him to have food
on a Wednesday night and they came and
they did they found food and they
brought their mom one time and then
their mom met him and they got married
married and that's supposedly how my
parents met
wow okay so your parents meet one thing
leads to another yes I'm assuming no
Immaculate
Conception
perhaps and then you enter the world
what were doctor's expectations of you
they were upside down so because my
mother had had previous children she had
had three and she was a
widow they were also in their teens they
supposed they assumed that I had the
same father so they didn't test their
blood so there was a factor in the blood
I think it was an Rh factor but it
created what they call [__] blood disease
so it required when I was born that I
had a transfusion um there were a few
other things my mom had lupus connective
tissue disease which created tumors in
her uterus and so my legs developed
around those so they were twisted up and
I think out of that I mean it's an
interesting we can go in this further
but out of that when I was born there
was a product of a little the force Gump
thing I had to wear braces on my legs
like force Gump to get around but also I
had fine and gross motor problems I
couldn't control my hands it was kind of
the joke of trying to clap the hands
three times at the therapist I was a
little bit better than that I can clap
my hands but I couldn't do a lot more I
had to when I learned to write have a
large diameter pencil that had was
through a rubber ball and I had to learn
to you write that with both hands up
until about the second grade so I had a
lot of therapy which I think that idea
of persistent learning through
overcoming an obstacle like that has
been helped me be resilient with
acquiring a lot of skills over my
lifetime could you say more about your
father so was
he
blind for your entire life did that have
some
onset and how did that shape who he was
and of course the implicit question is
you know how did that affect you but
let's let's start with a simpler version
of the question could you just tell us
more about your father so my
father was he was a short man and I
think that that factors in CU he was
about
5'4 so it's pretty quite short he was
very physically fit he climbed rope with
without using his legs he was very quick
to go to a fight when he was younger and
then one time when he was going into
college he was studing to be a
CPA and he had some kind of bout he had
tubercular
menitis that affected him for about a
year year and a half it was a very
serious disease at the time I mean still
is but at the time was more pervasive
and it made him blind during the product
of this year and he became kind of Born
Again somebody had come to visit him and
witness to him during that time he
decided he was going to change the
course of his life become a minister and
that I think made him a very dogmatic
Minister too he really embodied himself
thinking about the difference of Paul
versus Saul in the
Bible and when he came out he was a
traveling Minister for most of my early
life he would travel visit
churches I think one of the creative
parts that I really took from him was
that he would travel to a church not
knowing what his presentation was going
to be but he would find an animal along
the way a turtle crossing the road and
that became his presentation he would
sit it in front of the pulpit and
everybody would circle around him and
talk about the as an analogy or a
metaphor and he was able to connect
these ideas and meanwhile I would sit in
the back with my little braces and a
usually a pen and paper and tried to
draw everything that was going on and I
art was a big thing for me and it had
been for him before he had lost his
sight so I think those influences factor
in later to some of the other things but
I think one of the bigger takeways
wasn't the blind spots he had through
vision although it did help that when we
would walk around I would try to be his
eyes for him there was this tuger war
that he didn't want anybody to know that
he was really blind he didn't often
emphasize that he would often walk with
a confidence level that was Ill suited
to his yeah his eyesight yeah and to his
shin s because he would run full force
into a park bench and come tumbling over
it but he created this ministry that
was inside of government subsidized
housing what people people think is the
hood and he would get beat up in front
of me and by gangs sometimes or not
gangs but just small groups I guess you
call gangs where was this again can you
remind me well now it's branded as a TV
show the Ozarks ah okay but the city was
Springfield Missouri MH he would go into
those neighborhoods he would go he would
set up his ministry inside of a a
laundry mat and he would draw the kids
in with a story he bring Kool-Aid and
cookies every Sunday he did that for 20
years and they would come in and he
would tell them these stories it meant a
lot to him he was non-denominational but
he was very dogmatic about his specific
interpretation of scripture which to me
myself jumping ahead I'm agnostic I I
don't I'm not an atheist but I'm not
subscribed to any religion but it was
such an interesting Learning
lesson I think about the difference
between most people would judge somebody
by their perceptual blind spots of not
being able to see but sometimes it's
worse the stories that we tell ourselves
and how that limits our perception we'll
definitely come back to this okay right
like perception story perception shaping
story story shaping perception I want to
talk a lot more about this but since
it's something you just mentioned the
agnosticism did you start off religious
and then at some point along the way
become agnostic was it a response to
perhaps your father's dogmatism how did
you get to self-identifying in that way
I started off as religious which I think
is the same thing people start off as
extremely patriotic to their certain
country where they're born or where you
bro go family where they're very
religious would be under that flag as
well and my father had me study a lot of
different types of
scriptures from Jehovah's Witness to the
Mormons to because he wanted to be able
to debate those for a lot of different
topics the book of Hebrew he wanted me
study King James for its specific
interpretation I had a debate in debate
groups for evolution and Chism that's
why I was on teams that did that I went
I was in a Bible quiz team where I would
Buzz these buzzers and quote scriptures
and went to the world championships and
that and placed in the world
championship so it's all these things as
a young kid that I was deeply entrenched
in that world and there was this just
poking at this thing
that the certainty is what flagged me
just the absoluteness of my father's
answer and it was in justos of what was
happening on the other side of my family
so my mother and this shifts to the
other side is it was a dichotomy between
the two cuz she had been a widow and she
had raised these three kids that her
husband had died very early and two of
them had picked up this Beyond a hobby
of how they were making money on the
other side of the law from stealing
things running small hustles they never
called it pickpocketing but they would
steal from people at the zoo when they
were leaning over to watch things
animals being fed they would cut their
pockets or steal their bags at sporting
events through bleachers mostly
opportunistic but later it evolved one
of them went in the military when he
came out he started working again like
the series Ozark I I feel like that
route that was in Ozark is probably what
my brothers associate with it but with
some type of trafficking group that was
mov drug traffing drug trafficking up
through that pipeline one of my brothers
also did smuggling for firearms uh so
moving those in and out so it became
very intense and I was exposed to some
of that at the same time that I was
grown up with my father as a devout
minister so it was really a fascinating
jposition between those two worlds that
seeing deception in that true sense of
the word of what we often think it to be
but yet also he was okay with my
brothers as people that he he didn't
know that that's what they did but I got
to see both sides of that and they did
other things publicly they were truck
drivers or other things and exceptional
people in many ways but it taught me to
see the gray I think back to your other
question now became when I started to go
to church I would sneak out of the back
of the church when Services transitioned
I'd sneak off to another church and say
well if the simply God believe that
tongues is the first physical initial
sign of baptism in the Holy Spirit then
what do the Baptist believe and then go
see their tenants and then as I bounced
around I noticed that there were just
lots of little slices of different views
of perspectives which to me has
continued to follow me through my life
of anytime somebody claims a truth is
maybe we need more perspectives on this
H when does Ben Stone enter the picture
wow that's a great name and how old are
you how dark do you want to get I can
take it LI or dark or gray you pick
dealer's Choice okay I mean we've gone
dark on this podcast before so we can we
can go there but I'll pop in out so just
as a transition once upon a time I had
had a pursuit to become a syndicated
cartoon artist I was about 12 13 14
going through that and I was pretty
confident that I could pull it off I
wanted to be the youngest one there was
a guy who was imitating Gary larsson's
single panel
cartoons and I had six months of
character sheets I was going to send
them out to get syndicated and my
parents didn't understand what this was
or what this weird thing I was doing
they just knew I like to draw and do
cartoons but I think it's important to
understand the energy of what that was
and then there was a fight and parents
have fights with their kids with their
teens it's just mine was a little bit
more intense my father thought I was
possessed so they tried to evoke a demon
out of me because of the cartooning not
because of the cartooning but because of
some argument that we had but I see the
argument so I say this as proximity to
my large case of six months of cartoons
my
parents some variation of a water
boarding process occurred and the water
poured over on all my
art and so that's the dark side that it
destroyed all the art and when you had
that much work investing it's a reset
how do you start over what do you too
and for me as a kid that was what I
pictured as my escape the cartooning was
going to be your Escape Plan yeah mhm
from that world I was down in our
basement I was going through some boxes
and I found this little magic Gadget it
was a piece of plastic looked like a
thumb and I was very curious about what
that was and somebody said it's magic
trick I said well how did that end up in
our stuff so I call a magic shop that
was downtown and there's this guy picked
up the phone he was probably 70
something at the time his name was Ben
Stone so long way around to answer your
question mhm and Ben Stone I said I so
I've got this plastic thumb I don't know
what it is I said is this do I act like
my fingers cut off what do I do I'm like
14 I'm very precocious I'm borderline at
this choice in my life like I'm
shoplifting I'm running away from home
for Le two weeks at a time living out in
the woods sometimes I'm kind of a
transition place of which way I choose
as my pth life that's a vulnerable yeah
place where you could have inflection
points absolutely or vectors in a lot of
different directions and I had lots of
ingredients to go a certain way later as
I met people in my life I resonated with
them because of that because I had that
tree I had that fork to make a decision
so Ben had a big impact at that decision
and that's why I wanted to give you the
context for it for sure yeah I
appreciate that and so what happens then
you're like I have this fake thumb what
do I do Ben says come to the magic shop
downtown Springfield is about 12 miles
from where my house was so I rode a bike
I went with a friend and went down there
and he didn't show me anything about the
fake thumb but he used it as a trap he
he made this coin move around you're
kind of guy yeah which is great yeah
it's exactly what should have happened
to me and he he moved the slide of hand
with the coin he made it jump around
disappear jump through his clothing jump
through his
body I was fascinating because I was
thinking if this old guy can do this I
could probably pull this off
myself and then he pulled out a deck of
cards and I called this fali deck and he
did bunch of tricks with that he says so
here's a choice this kind of like a red
pill blue pill this deck of cards you
can walk out of here and for $ five
you'll be able to do 50 tricks without
even practicing or here's this big book
and it's going to take a lot of study
maybe in four or five years you'll be
able to do slide a hand with almost
anything but it's your choice and it was
his way of vetting at that point I think
and I didn't have money either way that
wasn't the plan so I I went back rode my
bike back to my house and I sold some
stuff at a pawn shop and came back the
next day and bought that book and for
the first year year I just spent my time
by myself studying the coin magic by
myself so I want to pause because we're
going to pick up on this particular
thread but I want to rewind I think just
a few years cuz you're around 14 15 at
this point yeah so I think this takes
place a bit earlier you mentioned your
father and the animals that then become
the parable or part of the sermon yeah
you can't believe everything you read on
the internet but is it true that you
also used to take in orphaned animals I
did okay so could you tell me more about
this wow do you have a research
Department that's great got te teams
everywhere eyes and ears on the ground
yeah so I'm curious how that came to be
and if it I don't want to make it too
leading of a question but how that has
informed or how it reflects who you are
wow it's very Salient I
think when I was like eight or so
one I I guess earlier when I would take
walks with my father he couldn't see
things but he he would stop me when we'
go for a hike through Woods or something
you'd say if you look around you right
now within 5 foot there's a world
there's lots of Little Worlds there's
little communities of things that are
happening you just have to find them so
find them and tell me about them and
that was a big
thing I saw a lizard on a tree and he
said walk straight to it and it's going
to run around the tree when it does
reach straight around behind it and cup
your hand and he taught me that I could
catch a lizard by walking around the
tree because it go to the same position
there's kind of a pattern to that and he
taught me this perspective taking for
Animals I think helped a lot it's a
variation of empathy that I think
transferred later on for me but I had at
that time squirrels raccoons I babysit
bear for a weekend that baby bear hold
on let's take the bear as an example yep
so bear drop off see see you next week
what what exactly happens how do you get
how does the bear make its way to you
apparently now they have a mail order
service bear in a box but just kidding
be careful on the internet you might get
something you don't expect if you try to
order that my address is online um so at
that time I had raccoons which is a
predecessor to getting a bear as I've
learned the bear starter kit I had
worked with humane society as a
volunteer from a I was a early
entrepreneur from the time I was five I
was always doing some kind of hustle was
that encouraged did that just emerg sort
of out of your programming out of the
box is was something other people were
doing it sounds like you had a family
that was sort of active in
extracurriculars if you brought the
definition of extracurriculars yes well
there's a specific moment so at 5: I was
at Walmart and I saw a toy rifle that I
really wanted it was a single bolt had a
little toy bullet inside of it and I
thought I must have this and my parents
didn't have money to buy it but they
said if you want to get it you're going
to have to come back and buy it but
write down this number and I wrote down
the number the the cost of what it cost
to get that and they said it's probably
going to be there for this amount of
time so you got to figure out how to get
that much money and so I had to learn to
count that much money so I had to learn
how to count the coins was Finding
pennies everywhere doing anything I
could to try to get jobs from everybody
and I got all these pennies and nickels
and dimes and they took me my dad walked
with me to the bank and we got these
paper rolls and he had me put everything
in there mhm and as we put the paper
rolls up we count up these dollar bills
and other things walked to the store and
I brought all these paper rolls of coins
and paid for that rifle and it was
probably about a month's work and after
that I thought how can I do this faster
than going around collecting pennies so
I was like how else do you make money
cuz there's a lot of things in the store
I
want and so from paper rout to creating
a little art business where I had a
knack for drawing when I was a kid even
though I was disabled a little bit I was
early to pick up on 2D perspective
two-dimensional perspective or
three-point perspective MH and so it
gave me a unique Insight I think at that
age that I went back to a back of a
comic shop took down the Flyers of all
the artists that were the best and said
hey if I bring you work will you instead
of take give me a percentage will you
teach me lessons and so I started
mentoring get and finding mentors very
young and that has persisted with
everything I've learned since then okay
we're going to talk about mentors how
does how does the the be in a box F into
this so you get paid to babysit Bears no
I it was a slight add changent so so I'm
in yeah yeah yeah noing podcasting but I
was along that so I was doing lots of
little efforts like I was used to
working jobs and I went to Humane
Society and I volunteered for a couple
of weekends uh to help out and I saw a
puppy get euthanized cuz it didn't have
enough space
and I was like eight and that hit me
pretty hard cuz they just didn't have
space and I was drawing a lot and I was
really interested at that time in being
an architect so I redrew spaces of their
cage to do triple stack cages and they
ended up saying they' used the idea so
more dogs could stay there and they
added me on to the board of my local
human site when I was like eight that's
incredible so then I said I want to help
other kind of animals cuz I like all
these kind orphan animals and I studi
their habitats and I never have said
this stuff out Li so I it really paints
a picture of myself that I haven't seen
before but it's fun then raccoons were
part of it they were orphaned and they
brought two raccoons to me and I raised
them and re acclimated them back to be
released into the wild and I had a knack
for that of getting animals to
successfully re-release into the wild at
an early age what do you think made you
good at that when you can't walk the
same as everyone else you end up
watching everyone else and you become a
people Watcher and there's a lot Comming
ity between animals and people in those
ways you start to do a lot of what I
call perspective shifting of jumping
into their head to think why would they
make that decision why would they not do
that I think that helped with the
animals because I had to figure out how
do I teach raccoons how to vage how do I
create little plastic containers with
mud and crawfish and what are the things
they're going to need and why are they
not adopting that why would they so I
very interested in behaviors of that at
that time so that's probably part of it
but then this lady who was kind of ment
ing me on that her name was Charlie stof
Camp she was a fascinating lady who had
been a law enforcement officer that got
mauled in a bar fight where she was
trying to pull some people on bar fight
and then sliced open her arm and she was
had a single arm but she took care of
Bears and Buffalo and all sorts of crazy
things she's a powerful lady and she
said hey you it's amazing what you just
did with these raccoons would you like
to take care of this young bear for me
for the weekend it has diapers and it
needs to be fed and it was magical it
was an awesome little milestone at that
time wow how old were you I was probably
nine 8 to probably 8 to 10 is when I was
doing those things yeah so it seems that
to your parents credit they were open to
you having a bear in the house well not
in the house not so much where so where
did the bear in the diaper stay I had a
habitat that I was using For the
raccoons that was square footage large
enough to let them move in Rome like a
shed type of place or was it more of an
outdoor enclosure it was an outdoor
enclosure that was Chained and fenced in
with some options for it to go inside
that could work for yeah but I had to
build a lot of those and my mom had a
background of farm so she taught me how
to build a lot of those I lived in the
city but we had a strange backyard
strange
house so let's pick
up
with the book and the path of magic so
how do you go then
from let's just say broad magic
generalist magic to what you have become
so well known for
H it like well first you go to med
school and then you figure out your
specialty yeah and then like you do your
residency and you're like okay actually
I'm not really great at this but I am
pretty good at this so let me Zig and
zag was it that type of process or how
did you sort of meander your way maybe
it wasn't Meander maybe it was a direct
line I was always kind of Full Force in
whatever I did yeah and I think that
that's part of it
that sometimes when we're trying to get
to a place and we just feel like we need
to get to that place we can change the
vehicle mhm we just know that we're on
that journey and that's often what it
was I knew I was getting out of where I
was and that was a big thing for me is
getting out of the place where I was
growing up so at that point this was
going to be my next question at what
point did you have the conviction that
magic or some variant of magic could be
your sort of metaphorical bus ticket yes
out of that place in the way that you
hoped cartooning would be yeah which is
a fun combination yeah so the book was a
dense read and I think it helps me
though that now when people try to learn
from Magic they try to learn it without
mentors and from YouTube videos where
they don't have to deal with people and
so you don't have to do the perspective
taking in the management of a person in
the same way when you're first learning
it you're just learning it to fool a
camera through a certain angle and you
only have to do it once so it's a
different thing and at that time when I
was read from a book I didn't have a
mentor so I was reading this Den
copy that described how something was
supposed to look
magical I was trying to transfer that
into an idea and doing that for in front
of a mirror and I started to find ways
to do it whether they were the way the
book intended or not but what I had at
my disposal I think is also because i'
been exposed to like my brother's
stealing things and other things it
allowed me to have a perspective that I
didn't have the same Baseline other
people did for guilty knowledge for an
anxiety that happens when you get caught
and so I was willing to try things that
other people thought made them shake and
made their skin Shake make them do and I
was very comfortable with doing a lot of
unusual things with magic that really
started to shape like for instance
instead of trying to do what you can
call complete vanish where a coin's
going to disappear but rather than
retaining in your hands you hide it
somewhere in a pocket or somewhere else
I thought why not put it on another
person they won't find it there and I'd
had that experience one time I was
shoplifting
early probably 13 and what were your
go-to shoplifting items and were you
shoplifting to use them or to resell
them or something else there was a a
group you call them hobos back in the
day but there was a group of people that
lived out behind the some of the grocery
stores and they knew sometimes when I
run away from home I'd go stay with them
and sometimes they would need food or
they need other things or cigarettes or
other things like
that and one time when I went in I stole
some cigarettes I didn't smoke
but had stole some cigarettes and the
guy kind of recognized me and he came up
to talk to me this the kid who never
buys anything well he he recognized me
from I think my family I live close by
and he came up to talk to me and I
didn't want to be found with him and so
is he says I think he saw me do
something so he went to check me and I
had it was an interesting thing just by
Instinct I didn't put them on any kind
of pocket on me I had left him
underneath my arm facing out the back so
as he's checking my pockets I reach
around behind behind my back with my
right hand I removed the cigarettes from
there and I load him in his apron that
was on him so he definitely wasn't going
to look there and I left and I got away
but later he's going to find those
cigarettes in his apron but I think that
influenced my style of magic too because
very quickly I would take traditional
magic effects and things that would be
called like a impossible location where
something disappears from myself and
appears somewhere else said well why
doesn't it appear on someone else what
else can I do with that so I started
developing a lot of that too so where
did you go after the book right you have
this
initial Tome mhm that you're digesting
and shaping and experimenting with yeah
course
one you flip the last page you've tested
what there is to test I was trying to
find a magician I had seen when I was
like seven
and there was a guy that I thought he
was a magician but I didn't realize it
was a magician quite at the time and
when I was like second grade this guy
had come through my school
and it was just an announcement from the
principal that called the teacher out of
the room and there's this guy working on
the window he was in overalls and he was
working on the window and he asked one
the kids to help measure a rope and then
he cut the rope and it went back
together it wasn't a show it was just
these magical things were happening from
this old guy that was fixing the window
and then everything came out of his
toolbox they he was trying to use was
doing some weird thing but it wasn't a
magic so it wasn't presented in that
social contract track and it hit me over
the head and later I found that that
plastic thumb that I found was a gift
from to my parents from him so later I
went back to try to find him I found his
widow and she told me about this magic
club that was in my hometown and when I
showed up they said oh you're new to
Magic and then I started doing some
things and they why can you do that and
there's two things I could do I
manipulate coins make them appear
disappear small objects like that and I
could do what's called equivoke or an
influence of a series of choices that I
learned early on when I was eight from
some book but I had used it over the
years and I could do that which was a
category of minism that is jazz-based
and did you say Jazz yeah my whole style
is jazz-based which is and that's an
important thing yeah yeah please say
more so and and equivoke just so I
understand what that means I'm trying to
dissect the atmology but I'm going to
get stuck in the weeds there yep you are
in very subtle ways directing someone's
Choice even though they think they have
free will in selection you give the
illusion of agency I see yeah you're
allowing them to play a game of darts
but you're painting the bullseye on the
wall after the dart is landed I see and
yet they don't realize that they fill
with conviction that that was all
choices that they made that they
navigated to and that takes a fluidity
of thought there's little feedback loops
that people you kind of blend in the
Segways and people don't notice those
and the way you use your word
and so the way that please yeah correct
me if if this is a a lazy or inaccurate
description but for people who don't
know the term mentalism one way that
could manifest is someone demonstrating
mind reading or something along those
lines what is the right way to think of
mentalism I think there's a variety of
ways but if you think about card magic
when you see magician pick a card where
did that come from it came from at one
point some card mechanics
or card Sharps that you did at cards
some of that filtered across and made it
into the entertainment world and there's
this other category of a lot of those
from thieves and things factored into
magic there's an interesting genealogy
there I think but mentalism came from
psychics and mediums M and that category
was this impersonation that I have some
type of acceptional ability to read
minds influence predict the future talk
to the dead whatever it might be the
different label is that
as a camp mentalists usually will not
claim that they have real Powers they'll
say that they're doing it under the flag
of entertainment versus psychics and
mediums who often use the same tools
will sometimes convey that they have
those god-given Powers yeah got it okay
so you could do the coin manipulation
yes and you also had some mentalism game
and they and they were like wait a
second you just said you were new all
this so how are you able to do these
things and you gave the specific example
of the equivoke yeah and then what
happen I told them I had read these
books and I had learned it on my own and
they were surprised by that and they
said well that must have felt good yeah
yeah it was nice and I also learned
early there that even though I learned
some things wrong by their
interpretation he had created a new
thing and they said well that wasn't
what they meant I like oh that's great
so what did they mean now is that what
you mean by jazz
influenced like if you make a mistake do
it twice and then it's Jazz no it's a
different thing so if you think of a lot
of performance magic it is very sheet
music based very classical it's very
structured it's very there's a lot of
geometry and the sight lines and the
calculations of that there's very
precise scripting of what's going on my
style has always been very jazz-based to
a fault in many ways but that I would
feel constricted by any script so for me
as soon as I had an idea my landscape
was to try with an audience immediately
before I'd even try tested it out pick
up a turtle walk in front of that
audience figure it out yeah well yeah
jump off the cliff and build a play on
the way down but yes the turtle is a
great metaphor for that the first time I
did a show with my wife and initially we
had this a separate tangent to go down
but we were walking to go on stage and
there was a certain skill set we had
learned with each other and she said but
what's the structure for the show I said
I don't know I haven't met the audience
yet and I didn't and she was
like which is this Collision have two
different mindset which she's changed me
for the better but at that time I didn't
want to start until I met the audience I
like let's create this together because
I thought there was a value in creating
and to me early on in Magic that's what
I was trying to do too because all the
books said I had to do this phase one
then phase two then phase three it's
like I get that and that's useful for
some things but also I want the organic
feeling that this person feels like
they're having this experience
and it's not happening to anybody else
this only happened in this moment did
that magic club figure into your skill
development was it a launching pad where
did you end up going from there they
offered me books more books so you like
books yeah and they said well if you
could get through that book that you
first read then you why don't you take
these other books and learn some of
those things because there's this great
quote I don't know who it's attributed
to but when we buy books we think we're
buying the time to read them and I I
feel it's it's as my unread stack would
agree yeah and I think that that's what
they were suffering from at that time
say you have this energy you read my
books and teach it back to me genius
yeah so they did that to me and that was
a really cool thing there was there was
a couple of people that influenced a
magic trick of its own type it is yes
but Ben was a mentor he wasn't with the
club but Ben did some things he did one
thing there was um a magician I really
admired and who helped me on the
business side named Mark Sparks who was
a traveling performer who was brilliant
and I'd seen him make a coin fly up from
one hand to another and anything I could
try to excuse or slide a hand didn't
make sense of why that could happen and
other books I'd read it didn't make
sense of why that could happen so I went
back to Ben Stone in that shop we call
Mysteries magic shop I said Ben what is
with this coin I I don't know I think
it's this here's my hypothesis one two
three and he goes ah well that's
obviously Dariel Fitz said Fitz skky and
I said oh no that's on my radar and he
say well fitsy wrote three books it's a
Trilogy go read that and so I picked up
one of the books this psych Magic by
misdirection on the psychology of magic
I read it and it was a hard read and I
came back and I said B it wasn't in
there and he says while he wrote two
other books the trick brain and
Showmanship for magicians so I read all
those I came back and I said it wasn't
in any of those because I must be wrong
and Ben tricked me again he tricked me
to use my desire to learn how to make
that coin fly
to read three books that have influenced
me till this day of a very structured
analytical approach for performance that
I needed but also for the psychology of
magic and understanding how an illusion
is constructed in the audience's mind
and I needed that at 15 because I wasn't
thinking about that and so that was the
biggest thing I would say and there
there was many other people that from
that time period a Jo named ed Dillard
who was a yearound Santa Claus who did
amazing things he would go into to a
mall and he created experiences that was
a great thing cuz he was a year round
Santa Claus yes he lived it all year
right so anybody who saw him but when
you'd see him in a mall you you see
people go up and a kid sits on Santa
Claus but what would be affective with
him is a 12-year-old let's say AI at
Santa Claus and he says it's good to see
you Nick so what's been happening this
year Nick it sounds like you've had some
problems with your friend we want to
talk about it and he would say these
things and just know so much about
someone and he was Mentalist as well and
he not to also throw off that he had a
inner ear microphone in his ear and the
parents had the other side of it but he
had this great book of Latin that was
Santa's book and it was all carved out
of leather with this beautiful book and
he would tell anybody about anything
about themselves but through the ospice
of Santa Claus and I just loved this
beautiful approach that it wasn't so
much of what I saw magicians initially
getting a magic for was to fill a hole
in themselves they were hiding behind
what they're doing they're trying to get
this validation from somewhere and they
needed attention and that wasn't the
driver for me I was trying to figure out
is there something here I can create
Sparks in people an experience like that
guy did the guy did in my second grade
when he came in repairing the window or
the Santa Claus and so I think it
started to shape that I had one skill
set which outside of magic I could steal
things that I could blend in and there
was a few factors also I States a little
bit martial arts I had some
understanding of animation and all of
them kind of settled together to create
a style that I developed in animation
and form the style animation there was a
great book called The Illusion of Life
by Disney's
n what do you call them is nine men but
it it talks about the illusion of Life
how to create in just frame by frame
when you're hand drawing how to create
life motion and one of those is
secondary actions and what they call
slowing in and slowing out something
moving at this the top of a curve how it
will have more frames versus on the
bottom of a curve and I started
realizing there's overlaps in
relationship of that to iido when you
study iido there are certain half moves
and half circles and so I when I started
blending those together with slide of
hand I realized that I could lock people
and sorry in dance when you're doing a
cross body lead how does somebody know
that you have a lead and how do you
transfer that with your hands so by
putting those together I started to see
that I could manipulate a person's body
and tell them a story that they wouldn't
register consciously and I could lock up
their body without them knowing that I
had kind of locked up the mechanic lock
up meaning like gain hijack yeah put him
in a frame as you would say on the
street I could put him in a frame that I
didn't need other people a team of
Thieves to help me I could do it by
myself and I could use certain things
that would draw I noticed from animation
because of that there were certain
emotions that Drew attention and that
later became a thing too so a lot of
people try magic in some form or another
M very few people make it to the point
where they are performing giving Ted
talks Getting profiled By The New Yorker
Etc very few what were some of the most
important inflection points say picking
up where we left off right after reading
these books after
having these various
inputs I guess maybe could have been
during these various inputs like the
martial arts and the Jazz and the dance
and so on what were some of
the critical moments let's say could be
decisions could be interactions could be
people you meet
that helped to set the
trajectory I'm so fortunate to have had
some incredible people influence me
along the way and I've kind of surfed
through my career from person to person
that's made an impact on
me but back at that time there's one I'd
say that makes the most impact which is
my wife I'll Circle back to her CU she's
probably the biggest but at that
time when I was in Las Vegas I was
married when I was young and so it was
my first wife and I was when did you
first get married I was 18 18 okay yeah
so I was married I had a son who now I
have two kids I have a son who's 30 and
daughter who's six so fascinating two
different worlds but at that time I had
to provide for my family so it amped up
that entrepreneurship that I think made
it a very serious thing that I had to
find out how if I'm going to do this and
I I was in a j position Between Two
Worlds I had given up art because of
this incident with my father but in
school and high school I had some
teachers recognized that I shouldn't and
they pushed me toward design and
illustration and computer graphics and I
had two careers that I could do
simultaneously the design aspect of that
and then Moonlighting with the the magic
style and comedy clubs and things so I
was doing both those in high school but
then I was transitioning into doing that
full-time by the time both of those
simultaneously as I graduated high
school and there was a a gentleman who
was a touring magician from Las Vegas
came through town and he saw me
performing and he said you you should go
to Vegas I said yeah that's what
everybody says and he says come visit me
I said I've never flown on a plane
before I don't even know what it's like
outside of like Missouri and he says
come and I flew to Vegas to visit this
guy his name was Daryl Martinez they
call him the magician's magician and he
picked me up at the airport he drove me
straight downtown into a gambling spot
and he was a gambler showed me that
world and he said Vegas has everything
to offer but it will give you nothing
which was perfect for me cuz I love
working for it and I formed a model real
quick I looked at all the magicians that
were around me they blew me away they
had exceptional skills things I didn't
know were possible but they didn't have
everything they either had high skill
which I put underneath the talent they
had low business sense maybe or they
their ambition to take that effort to
the next place and the combination of
those were atrophied in different areas
and I felt like even if I don't have the
same skill level I can bring some of
that back or find other angles and so I
decided to move out to Las Vegas and to
try to go after that and then I'm
jumping through a timeline real quick
but I was initially working at doing a
couple design jobs and my second one was
for a series
of slot machine design designing the
animation sequences for slot machines
and doing all the illustration for that
and I was doing freelance artwork for a
hypnotist named Justin
trans and I was designing all this stuff
and he said why are you here he says for
a couple years you've been in this work
little place and you're doing freelance
artwork for me he say but your
performing capability says you you could
should do something else and I said
what's a good reason what lay out give
me one good reason he say wouldn't it be
amazing story sometime later in your
life if people said why did you quit
your job as an artist and become a
magician or performer full-time and it
was because a Hypno just told you during
a lunch
break I thought that was a great idea so
I went back into my job and I gave my
notice that day wow that was a Friday
what a gift well it depends on how I
mean I know you're sitting here so I'm
not sure what the intervening
experiences looked like but it seems
like a gift that was a big point so that
because that was a jumping point right
and it had a context in that I was a
senior designer at that time and the
company I was working for and the reason
why I didn't say their
name they had let off a large production
team that supported the graphics I did
I'd hand my designs to them they would
Port them across to bigger things they
let them go but they found a way to get
around their contract so they Outsource
them to another company and then let
that company fire them okay so they
wouldn't know any Severance or they
Dodge something they Dodge all their
Severance that's lame yeah yeah and that
made an impact on me so they just given
me a bonus they just given me a raise
and so was that that was the context at
that time that he said that well why are
you here and it wasn't about the money
for me and it was moment of yeah what
would happen if I did this thing I don't
know how but let me just clean the SL on
this thing and see what happens and
coincidences I still believe happen and
that weekend A friend of mine said hey
I'm going on tour for a couple of weeks
and there's a show called Caesar's
magical Empire and I was wondering if
you can come fill in for me that for
those two weeks and starting on Tuesday
I said uh perfect timing sounds great
I'll give that a shot what did you have
ready at that point like filling in does
that mean you have 30 30 minutes set a
15 minute set I'm not sure if sets the
right term 60 minutes cuz I think of
comedians working on standup material
and to get a polished hour I mean could
take years for some folks right so what
did you have when this opportunity falls
from the sky hey could you fill in
within the next week so I've been doing
it professionally at the same time so
even back in my hometown I had contracts
with I did restaurants I did
nightclubs I had 15 different contract
TRS at that per week so you had things
you knew had had already workshopped you
knew you could string them together yeah
and I I knew I could make an impact and
the big skill I had that was unique when
I came to Vegas I decided let's just
drop the other stuff and just focus on
the stealing because at that point there
was two other guys that were in that
space one of them had passed away he was
a friend and he worked at that place and
so it was a good angle for me to explore
further and more to differentiate
yourself yeah to different as a brand
and just paint a picture of the it's a
fascinating thing one my first show I
ever did in Las Vegas separate from
Caesars it was just a corporate event
for a large
corporation and it was a red carpet
event they had limousines pulling in it
was very different for Missouri boy when
I first moved out there and these agents
they said uh so all right go steal
things from people I guess and they gave
me $100 poker chips to give to people as
gifts and I went up to this guy and the
agent was watching when you say agent
this is someone who works at the casino
these are agents that hire for
entertainment in Las Vegas and they were
watching and they were trying to vet if
I was a good fit and the first guy okay
this is like your audition gig in a
sense kind of yeah if they're going to
hire me back again and so I walk up to
somebody that was important they brought
this big VIP up to me right away and as
I go to steal his watch his watch band
was very worn out and it snapped in two
pieces while I was stealing
it I could feel my ears turning red and
I just was running through the gamb do I
give this back to him which is more
important cuz I got a lot of pressure at
that moment and so I he I was performing
with him in another gent and then I said
oh and here's your watch and he's
shocked that I have his watch and as
he's before he even processed I said I
pulled out the other piece of his watch
and gave him the second piece of it
which was a leather band and I said see
that lady over there he goes what yeah
that lady I said yeah see her watch said
I'm going to let you see it a second
time this time I'm going to Ste her
watch I'm going to try to do it without
breaking it now that's a lot harder I'm
going to try to see if it's possible he
goes no you can't do that and I was
gambling on the idea that he didn't need
the money he probably knew that he
needed to replace this band but I'm
reframing it that hey that's a whole
another level you guys want to try it
and let's move past this idea that I
just broke his watch Jazz yeah yeah
which that's always script for yeah and
that's constantly what was required for
me because my first stay at Caesar's
Palace now flash I didn't take
cigarettes you took cigarettes in the
apron yes my career has been majority of
those right my first day after IID left
my job as a designer I come over to work
at Caesar palace I was accused of
stealing this lady's rings I was doing a
performance in front of a group and she
said my rings and her husband said
where' they go and she say somebody
stole them I hadn't even touched her and
I said what did you have and she goes I
had diamonds and rubies and emeralds oh
my and I just said oh I must have sent
them as a child support payment I just
turned as a joke and then the the
husband really got mad didn't like it no
and so once every cleared out they came
at me come up to me came at me too yeah
and he said give us the Rings I said do
you really believe that I have your
rings or are you joking and he says no
give us the Rings and he says we're
going to the police and they started to
leave I said stop don't walk away he
goes what said if you walk away right
now you'll never know if I have your
rings cuz I could hide them anywhere but
I want you to know that I don't so I'm
going to walk in front of you I'm going
to keep my hands out to the side you
watch me we're going to walk to police
together so we walked out in the casino
we went to sec security and I got strip
searched and his wife went up she was
very dramatic which ended up to me
conveyed that she was sincere about her
belief that she really believed that
that happened so then she up in her room
found her ring sitting on a sink and
she'd been washing her hands do you get
an apology I did that's good but I think
it also helped it wasn't just an apology
it helped me secure a job there Beyond
feeling in for a friend I got it for 5
years so that five years came from how I
handled that situation and over that
time I had people grabb my throat pull
out a gun one time pull out knives I had
hold on a second this is at shows right
after a show dur shows all over the
place I've had every variation of that
happen and that's because they think you
have stolen something or they're upset
that you or maybe I have yes but it was
in a social context of entertainment
right right right right yeah but still
that's a different thing than if you
mess up on a magic trick if you mess up
on a magic trick they caught you look I
understand how your trick works
in the space I was playing it was
accusations law enforcement lawsuits and
I was constantly deing with that I
learned certain rules don't steal from
someone who's been drinking don't steal
from someone who has Alzheimer's or any
potential for that because that's a
really hard one to fight your way out of
if they believe they had something they
didn't and I started making my own set
of rules and it changed one big thing in
my style which was all right I want to
treat this like a vampire I'm going to
tell vampire vampires couldn't had to be
introduced into the household across
you're right they need to be invited so
I'd say in 3 minutes I'm going to be
wearing your watch try to catch me and
if they say yes then but that was the
first time I had ever seen that happen
when I had studied the history of
theatrical pickpocketing of thing there
wasn't that open challenge that beware
this is about to happen if you engage
that's the game we're going to play are
you ready but it now meant a whole
different thing but it came from all
those concerns and lawsuits and
everything it almost happened never ever
landed but now I developed this style
that was a very different style very
potent style but instead of surprise it
was suspense yeah yeah exactly it was
suspense it was also like a preemptive
strategy yes right so you would have
less need to be good at reacting yes
because there setting the ground rules
and in getting invited as a vampire so
at what point then you said five years
is it within that span that Jimmy Carter
and the Secret Service show up yes so at
that time I had been there and I I'll
give you more context so when I was
performing it was a specific role at the
beginning of the show 24 people would go
into a certain area and they'd be there
for 10 minutes before they went on to
the next part of the show during that
time I would steal from four people and
pass their items off for the function in
the show and one person then I would
bring up front steal all of his stuff
while everybody's watching and give it
back and then later everybody would find
it and it comes back to them later I
would do that every 10
minutes six times an hour five hours a
night oh my God five nights a week for
five years so some math is somewhere
around 200,000 people plus my side gigs
that it became a lab for me to
experiment can I take someone's glasses
while they're wearing them and what does
that do is it possible can I steal their
belt what are the boundaries and that
was a place for me to experiment on the
aspect of
that so could you please tell the story
of
the Secret Service probably near the end
about 3 years after I've been performing
at Su
Palace there was a special night when I
come into work and they had a big
meeting before the show and the manager
said we have a previous president of the
United States coming in to visit and
we are going to have some people go home
that haven't have background checks
different rules yeah because they had
done background checks on all of us M
and he said there you be photo ops as he
goes through the show it's he's got a
small party with him but the whole
theater is just going to be sectioned
off for that they have Secret Service
we'll be here so don't be alarmed but
they'll be stationed throughout the
casino and throughout the theater and
then we were all departing and he said
but Apollo they asked you not to meet
the president not to shake his hand they
they wanted to get in the news if you
were to steal from him and everybody
just kind of laughed and I went back to
him and said that's not I'd like a
picture with the president it was Jimmy
Carter at that time not that I was in
the era Jeremy Carter he was an ex
president at that time he was on a tour
book
tour and he said but you know they
didn't say anything about the Secret
Service I said what does that mean go
they didn't say that you couldn't steal
from the Secret Service you didn't hear
this from me yeah but do you think you
could and I'm so happy they he posited
that then versus now because I'm in my
20s I probably wouldn't do those things
now in the same way I mean I Still Still
from Secret Service today but it's a
different context um wait a minute yeah
all right we'll come back to that there
you go get back to
that all those Secret Service Bar
Mitzvah that you go to yeah it's a thing
okay else moved to Washington DC yes
okay so you wouldn't do it exactly the
same way and then what unfolds so you
you get this side chat which is like
technically they didn't say you couldn't
do something with the Secret Service and
and then what he brings in the head of
security for Caesar palace they talk to
me about certain provisions and warnings
don't take any of their firearms don't
touch them that would still be
considered a felony if they do take you
to the ground it's on your own you're on
your own for this we have Deni plausible
deniability disavow all knowledge yes
and that this could be rather serious
which I thought was a really interesting
Challenge and so I I moved into that
I was approaching the show and as I was
moving through I saw two of them were
stationed at a certain point and I went
up and started to hit those guys and I
see kid it was the way I approached them
that got in their space I stole sold
several of their items so they're two
Secret Service agents I guess is the
right term maybe yes and to a lay person
to a civilian I think two more
complicated but maybe two actually
provides more surface area SL
opportunity but when you say you went
into their space could you paint a more
detailed picture of how you ended up
taking items from two very well trained
people who have a lot of situational
awareness who know what you do sure you
used a great word there you said surface
area and surface area they have a lot to
protect on themselves both where they
keep their firearms their credentials
the keys uh the itinerary all these
things so they just treat it as a whole
but it's got all these little parts and
I like to think of attention as like a
limited resource it's really useful to
think of kind of the economics of
attention if they spend their attention
one place versus another how do you
toggle that and it's not traditionally
like look here and not there you're
curating their attention so in that
there's ways to approach it and it's
usually contextual it changes from
person to person and when I approached
them I hadn't had an experience with
anyone like that before and the context
was different they knew who I was
specifically when I walked up there's a
nickname for me in the show they called
me klepto they say it's not happening
was I think the first thing I heard from
them and I said no it shouldn't at all I
said yet I think is the word you're
looking for
right so I kind of pushed it boundaries
of their confidence
level because I was coming in pretty
confident and one of them Ste back as I
approached and there's a way that I
approach that gains access to someone's
space if you think of
someone's personal space as a bubble
their appri reception of how you get
into their awareness of their space it's
kind of shaped like an egg and it's
larger up front it's narrow on the sides
and it's shallow on the back and you can
break eye contact with someone to sneak
underneath that as you move through I
can show you more of that later but as
you gain access there's a way of
approaching from the side that can often
help so when I started to S up next to
one of the gentlemen to show him
something he stepped back and they have
a term for it called maintaining
occupied space and it also indicated to
me with a slight
brush that in my world I have to know a
lot of Fe from what's inside people's
pockets and the printing of a jacket
what it means what being able to make
pretty good estimates of what a good
Target is inside of the outline of a
pocket so as soon as he stepped back on
the left it indicated to me that he
might have a firearm on that side versus
on his right side so it was probably
underneath in a holster underneath his
jacket MH so I just acknowledged it I
put that on the surface I said you're
very well trained I said it's going to
be much harder to do anything with you I
said you've been doing this for a while
and he says yes I've been doing this for
a while and I said okay so I'm going
have to do it to you sir and so I leaned
into the next guy and the next guy's
like that's not happening and he was
very serious but now as I'm facing him
and this other gentleman is
here he doesn't realize that he's giv me
access from the side the first guy yeah
the first guy he thinks he's off the
clock he thinks he's off the clock and
that's one of the things by setting the
expectation he thinks he's done and the
play has moved on but now I reach
underneath my arm I steal from inside
his jacket and I steal what I found to
be his credentials it was wallet
passport shaped and I steal his glasses
from his outside pocket and I steal a
couple things and as I was talking to
the other guys as you're doing does the
other guy notice no he doesn't notice
and he can't see because he's watching
my hands and they're training to watch
hands but there's all these pause points
I learned over the years from different
thieves and other ones of holding out
places and if I steal something you're
not going to get to see it go in and out
of my pocket or anything it's going to
go somewhere else so I can put it on
them in a more accessible spot or I can
put it on me another place so I did some
of that but at the end of that with the
two guys I said you know I didn't get
anything said for this I don't really
know what it is and I pull out this
paper that was kind of trifolded and as
I'm opening up I I see what it is it's
now the itinerary where they're taking
Carter to and I said I can't really read
it with these glasses on he realizes
that I'm wearing his glasses that were
in his pocket and he goes hey he takes
my glasses and he looks at the paper and
he says Hey and he snatches it away I
said you know I really don't think you
should read that without the proper ID
and then he real reaches in pocket and
he realizes he doesn't have the
credentials and the other guy's laughing
very hard at him I'm sure and he said
I'm not going to be the one o dad's not
going to be happy with that when he
finds out and so they said he says
you're going to do this to the other
guys so he got on his Mike and he starts
telling me to go to other teams so I now
have an advocate and in to approach the
other teams because this guy's sending
me because he didn't want to be the only
one but that's kind of why I mentioned
about the Jazz I mean I didn't know I've
never stolen with somebody with
presidential itinerary and credentials
and glasses in that combo before but I
have to kind of add lib with what I find
and how I give it back and it is a
unique thing that he knows is the only
time I've done that is with him until I
did it to the other
guys so what was the significance if any
of that whole
evening to you or your career maybe it
was indirect in the sense that it that
increased your confidence that enabled
you to do X Y and Z but if there was
significance what was the significance I
think Legend is too strong of a
word but it but there are things was
like a good story it does it gives
people a story to tell and it did and it
was one of a handful of Legends or lore
I guess lore is a better thing that
traveled Beyond me and I I found that
lore can take you so fast so far but
also it can encapsulate what people
think you are versus what you are and it
can be hard to under promise and overd
deliver when people have this
expectation of what you can do for cuz
it spread into oh you stole their
bullets and you took out their bullets
out of their guns and I've heard all
sorts of variations of that that I it
began working for the government from
that day forward William wace 12T tall
shoots flaming lightning out of his ours
it was much better when people
underestimated me because working
against overconfidence was a great way
to play mhm pros and cons right pros and
cons yes I was asked to speak for the
Secret Service it was around a time
where there was a shooting at the
Pentagon and there were two officers
outside and a Gentleman had approached
and he drew firearms and both of them
missed it and even though they thought
they were watching for his hands but
they were both Ted on a similar thing
and there's an interesting thing in
Psychology called intentional blindness
Dan Simons and his C shab was his
partner they did a book called Invisible
Gorilla where you watch basketball being
passed and gorilla Incredible video yeah
and I like to refer to that as task
blindness I think it's a more
approachable term but when someone is
tasked they often miss other things and
at that time I was asked to come speak
to the Secret Service afterwards so I
was like I'm not being arrested I I
guess this is a good thing but now I'm
traveling to DC and I'm going to get
talk to the Secret Service and I was
asked about task blindness and
intentional blindness and this
overlapped into two fascinating
neuroscientists that I met Steven mnik
and Susan Martinez K and they were have
been studying magic and visual Illusions
but they were also very interested in
cognitive Illusions and in that space
they wanted to see what could be done
with attention and they approached me
and said can we do an experiment do you
have any ideas and at first it was like
a little um session where they had
different magicians that were Legends
pen and Teller specifically teller
talking about theories and they were
seeing is there anything there to pull
research out of and I posited that I
think we only have two
Sidelines and this circles back to my
early days with animation and I said
I've noticed when I'm stealing that if I
move in a straight line that there's a
transition point from A to B that when
something is no longer at a that people
expect to be there they bounce back
their tension bounces back like a rubber
band to B but if I move in a half
circle from A to B when we get to that
destination Point nobody ever looks back
at their point of origin I said so I I
sense that there's two types of sight
lines and there's a kind of suppression
that happens during those and I think
that that's an interesting place to
experiment with and they said yes it is
we could do that with ey tracking
software and we did and it turned out to
be right and that was the change that
was the flip of a switch cuz then I was
part of a paper that they published in
nature magazine nature journal and then
I was asked to speak at the
international Society for Neuroscience
10,000 neuroscientist you broaden your
lane it did or you gained more Lanes
yeah and it when it realized it wasn't
just me stealing but that that same
concept of psychotic versus smooth pursu
ey movements and their impact on
different things started to Branch out
in other areas and then I was asked to
speak on attention and the current
models of attention at MIT and Harvard
and other ones it all changed right
there how did you connect with the
scientists just so I can connect the
lore the stealing bullets right from
midair with the Secret Service to
connecting on the scientific side how
was that connection made teller from pen
tell it was teller teller said he was
approached about this and at that time
him and I become pretty good friends and
we spent a lot of time it together pen
was also a friend tell her was
interesting in like the research side of
it on the backside and he asked me to
come join at that effort got it okay I
want to pick up a couple of micro
gingerbread topics yep that I've let
alone that I've committed to myself I
would return to so the first is in terms
of making the coin levitate into the
other hand did you ever figure that out
I did okay a lot of Blood Sweat and
calluses but yes okay I think that gives
me the answer that I'm looking for cuz
we have a mutual friend Simon Cornell
yes and I don't want to speak school so
I'm not going to get into the how of it
I suppose but I've seen him do this and
just rest
assured it is so much harder than people
think it is it's something that your
body wasn't trained to do you've never
had a use for that and to train it to be
able to do that to make something
animate is a combination of unusual
muscles that people wouldn't usually use
yeah it is so much harder than people
can possibly imagine which makes me
think of speaking of teller presentation
that he gave I think it was at the
entertainment Gathering and he said I'm
going to show you a video and I think
there was a balloon involved or ball yes
he shows the the magic trick let's call
the performance on video he says all
right now I'm going to explain how I did
it yes and he explains it and then he
shows it again he says now are you more
or less impressed I'm paraphrasing here
tremendously but it was a love story
right it turns into a love story with an
effect that's why I thought was the
greater lesson of those him showing it
and exposing it was this beautiful piece
of him coming and spending time with
this effect and giving part of his life
to it yeah all right this second thing I
wanted to ask about you have thousands
tens of thousands of repetitions because
you're doing four people every what was
it 20 minutes 10 minutes 10 minutes
multiple times an hour over and over and
over again so you're getting a lot of
reps what do you do
when it doesn't work what's your
recovery or how do you handle that cuz I
can't imagine as you're experimenting
you must push the envelope and I imagine
I mean with any skill it's not going to
be 100% hit rate yeah so what do you do
even at let's say for instance the Magic
Castle it's like you see how people
recover when things don't work out
exactly as plant absolutely for me
that's part of the art I mean it's
fascinating so what what do you do in
those circumstances there's a subtext to
what you're asking that is unique to the
context in which I steal okay in that I
have a different social contract with my
audience than a thief does on the street
uhuh so because I can talk to someone I
get different access to their body I can
justify what I'm doing it function is
more like sparring in martial arts that
if they start to pick up on a thing
there's a feedback loop that I can
see and the cost of them fixating on
that catch comes at the cost of them
losing something else so as soon as they
start to detect one thing right if they
cover their head you go to the body yeah
and once they catch that one thing they
might find themselves three lbs lighter
in other places because they've lost all
these other things okay changes the
definition of fail fail getting caught
stealing a watch or a belt or glasses I
was pretty good at rolling with that and
improvising with those things and
realizing that if they started to catch
that I could turn it into another
situation MH and I would load strange
things on people like I loaded bag of
oregano on a grandma and I said what's
this from Grandma well hold on this is
actually the perfect place yes for me to
just read an excerpt for a profile of
you sure which was by Adam green and The
New Yorker and the title of this I
recommend everybody read this and if you
have anything you'd like to correct in
the piece we can cover that too but a
pickpocket's tail the spectacular thefts
of Apollo Robin so this is one of my
favorite paragraph Tails
yes when Robins hits his stride it
starts to seem as if the only possible
explanation is an ability to start and
stop time at the Rio a man's cell phone
disappeared from his jacket and was
replaced by a piece of fried chicken the
cigarettes from a pack in one man's
breast pocket materialized loose in the
side pocket of another a woman's
engagement ring vanished and reappeared
attached to a key ring in her husband's
pants a man's driver's license
disappeared from his wallet and turned
up inside a sealed bag of M&M's in his
wife's purse okay so hard for me to even
make any sense of half of that but
you're loading things on people is where
you were yeah I take things off I switch
them I alter them you're creating for
yourself options yes also right it's not
like you have one trick you're executing
and if you flub it trick is done that's
why I meet this Sheep music versus Jazz
they don't know where I'm going so we
can always change the path and in fact
when I used to work in situations where
I would just walk around with a group
which I miss because I don't really get
to do that I'm mostly a keynote speaker
now and but I used to do a lot of
corporate type
of events where I would move through a
crowd and I would walk up to the guys
and say so guys you know why I'm here
right I'm supposed to steal everything
you have and so I say that up front it
stops most
conversations and I said you got
anything on you and you just see them
check they would just bump their wallet
so that thing and I'm just clocking it's
like okay so I got the keys here this
you know exactly yeah so I'm making a
mental map and now I'm about to move
into the circle they telegraphed all of
their possessions yes because they don't
believe it's true they just were having
a
conversation and I'm now making that
effect she like okay that seems to be a
room key here that's over here this is
what here and I as I move through them
in real pick pocketing they call it
Fanning small movements with my elbow or
my hand can give me an idea of what
things are in a breast pocket or other
things and I it's like a shark taking
little nibbling bites like feeling thing
feeling things out yes and just taking
inventory you could say yeah and now I'm
crafting okay so or feeling out round
and boxing same thing right yeah people
are gauging distance they're seeing how
people react what's their pattern what's
their what are their defenses absolutely
what are their vulnerabilities yeah
which is interesting now that I don't
have that I've gone back to martial arts
because it was one of the few places I
could get that feeling and I I was
studying a Filipino style martial arts
and as I was new one of the things that
I could do in the first part was they
would go to draw a secondary weapons
sometimes like a trainer blade and it
wouldn't be there it was you can't do
that trick a lot but it's a great trick
when they go to draw and then it's not
there they're very surprised and now I'm
sure they're very
surprised all right so following this
gingerbread Trail I just wanted to
address a couple all
right your wife yes so you mentioned I
think that she's the most important
influencer had the biggest impact on you
your career how so yeah and on life in
general she brought I think when you're
a specialist in an area it's easy to get
so fixated that everything in your world
revolves around that and mine was all
around con artist thieves and I had a
soft spot for those guys I knew a lot of
those guys were intimate friends of mine
that had done things that you would
think of like Oceans 11 where they
pulled high on casinos and switched out
devices and things I knew those guys
well and that was my world it was my
Cadre of team and around that time had
this weird inquiry to do a TV show about
picking up women just because as a side
thing people said hey you know you seem
to be really good at this thing and I
wasn't ever a person who did notches on
the Belt but it it's another thing the
perspective taking it's related to that
and how you establish Rapport and things
there's a friend of mine who was taught
hostage negotiation he had a special
forces background he says hey why don't
we do this book together and we'll go
shoot this video and we'll ask women how
they would like to be approached and
then we'll put hidden cameras on them
and see when people approach them how
ridiculous people do approach him then
we'll talk about that and I said sounds
like a great idea and he calls me got a
film crew coming in and some models and
other things and he says hey we're
having this thing late night at a party
in Las Vegas at a all night spot he says
come out I said it's too late for me and
he says no just come when I show up he's
talking to a group of women and I
thought they were
probably escorts at that point because
professionals yeah because they were
close to the VIP section and it was a
small group younger women some older
guys at the table and I'd seen that a
lot in Vegas but when I get closer I'm
talking to him and one of the ladies in
the group as they were introducing
themselves she had a background in
psychobiology she had just graduated the
degree in that she was working as a
crisis counselor on a hotline talking
people off the cliff she would do some
pretty intense stuff and studied
abnormal psych and very kind of intense
playful and he said I was a thief when
he introduced me to this group of girls
and that is a hell of an intro like
you're going to get a conversation it
does one of them said can so I stole the
girl's engagement ring with the thing
and I did a thing with that and gave it
back and this lady that later turned out
to be my wife she asked me Can you steal
something for me I said what would you
like she says chocolate covered
strawberry from that table over there
and she points at this table nearby VIP
section I said got it so I grabbed a
menu walked over pretended to be with
the staff asked them if they're being
taken care of stole the chocolate
strawberry under the menu and then I
walked it and I threw it over my
shoulder to add a little flare caught it
I went to hand it to her and when she
went to take a bite of it I put it in my
mouth and I just winked at her so she'd
have to kiss me to get the strawberry
and it's that playfulness I think that's
the important thing it's Bal it's bald
it but it worked yeah but but it almost
didn't work because her advocacy and her
Academia and it was the opposite was too
slick and she felt that pressure from
the group she gave me the kiss but we
end up leaning against the wall talking
about psychology and that dove into a
deep thing she say have you ever thought
about this long phone conversations
later on but she said have you ever
thought about all the stuff you're
learning and how applaud applies to
bigger problems in the world and she was
the one that encouraged me to do the
event with the neuroscientist she was
the one that encouraged me to take the
peace with the New Yorker which I didn't
even know what the New Yorker was at
that point I turned it down twice Adam
green would tell you I was like he
somebody better over here it wasn't my
thing I didn't even barely knew who the
politicians were it wasn't my world I
didn't think about that she said let me
have you watch a debate and when I saw
my first presidential debate I went back
to tell her I said tell her you're a
Latin Professor what was that so why do
I know all those things they're so
similar to The Thing the yellow kid used
to do or Titanic Thompson used to do
this thing with this wait a second
meaning you observed a lot in the debate
yes that paralleled what you had learned
very similar Concepts and he could you
give an
example there was a term called Gish
Galloping I forgot the guy's name for
Gish Gish Gish Galloping Gish was a
debater who would often do a package of
assaults on a person of their human
character where he'd say during his
three-minute window of a debate he would
say my opponent would have you believe
this this this this this and then the
opponent's counter measure for that
becomes well they're overwhelmed and
they they don't know how to respond
because they got three minutes and he
paused a lot of questions and they don't
have three minutes functionally to
answer those
questions and that very similar to me
was a noise to Signal ratio piece that's
used to overwhelm people inside of a a
cash exchange was short changing and I
recognized that as one approach short
changing so like giving
somebody change but less change than
they and overwhelming a cash register
attendee at that time and using
ambiguous statements with different ways
that they could take that for and I I
can clarify more on that later but I
asked teller about and a counter to that
Gish Gallop for example back to equ
right for equivoke if somebody were
doing a series of personal
assassinations they also what they're
doing is duding their argument because
now if I say 10 bad things about you or
you said that about me then I'd say as
you can see he's very impassionate about
what he says but notice there's a
central theme between all of those that
central theme is X right and that's the
equivoke right I can take all the things
that you said repackage them as another
thing and because you diluted all your
points because you put them all into the
one bracket so the countermeasure that
is to delute that down give you one
point back and I hijack The Narrative
all right so you're talking to tell her
about this yes and he was a Latin
Professor okay so that wasn't thought
that was a euphemism or a joke he was an
actual Latin Professor he was before in
his career I said I said you know more
about Socrates and Plato so can you tell
me what and he says yeah you need to go
back read Plato's Republic you need to
study about Socrates and he started
prompting me to go back to learn this
route it's amazing yeah back to the
classics back to the classics so
from the chocolate strawberry in the
mouth to broader applications in in
psychology or at least harnessing
psychology recognizing maybe the common
threads across multiple domains that you
had already been exposed to and had had
Polished in your craft
to presidential debate to then reading
Plato and Aristotle yes and and the
driver of this was back to that was my
wife we had this unusual thing that we
she moved to Las Vegas pretty quickly
after we started dating where was she
she was in Los Angeles was it hard to
get her to move to
Vegas
it was a
negotiation but so in that because she
didn't want to come visit and be under
an obligation and so when I asked her I
said please come visit me and she said I
have a lot of work that I'm doing here
and I don't currently have the money to
do that and I said I understand can I
ask when you write what is your P per
page fee and she said my per page fee is
usually about this amount I said so if I
asked you to help me write this bio and
some other portions for me I would
actually be getting a discount by paying
for that and by paying for your airplane
versus paying for the writer's fee MH
and she said yeah I guess so I said all
right so come help me write my bio and
I'll buy you a plane
ticket when she came
out she helped me a different direction
that I wasn't solely focused on
entertainment and she also just because
of her counseling backg she really broke
apart a lot of my early childhood and
she had had these complexities too she
had moved from Vietnam and she had grown
up her father was incredible he would
wear police uniforms and help people
smuggle things in out of the country
while she was growing up so she had
these really interesting kind of
engagements with deception too that she
was trying to manifest through
psychology and at that time I was
Consulting for a mentalist named Darren
Brown in the UK doing some things for
him so she was fascinated by that with
her training in Psychology say well
that's not exactly what that is and then
at that time I had this group of Thieves
around me that were professional
criminals and she kind of became a den
mom to all them they would come if the
FBI was watching or the NSA watching our
house they would have seen all these
guys comeing in and out and she was the
den mom of all that she really helped
take us all for a turn wow okay all
right so this is this is off the map
this has nothing to do with the
questions that I've written down but I'm
curious when you're describing for
instance the semicircle a Tob versus the
linear a Tob MH it makes me think of
sports and exercise science and how the
practitioners the people on the field
the top coaches the top athletes are
always a few years ahead of the
literature and the science and so on
which is not to denigrate the science it
just takes a while people need to write
grants typically they need to really
pick and choose their
shots
and a lot of what's experimented with in
the field doesn't work and that's okay
as long as a few things really work and
I'm curious if given that you have this
broader awareness and you've had these
interactions with neuroscientists and so
on if there are any beliefs you have
based on your experience as a
practitioner around
attention or
perception that has not yet made its way
into the scientific circles absolutely
but you'd be willing to say you know
what I can't say it with 100% certainty
but would bet mhm that a b or c I think
in order to validate their research they
have to go after low hanging fruit which
is single variable yeah real life has
context and multivariable yeah and so
when you go out in the wild the reason
why sports or between conoman and Gary
Klein they did a lot of research on
First Responders to smoke jumpers and
other things the context of an expertise
is hard to boil down in a lab yeah and
super hard also really hard for
replication with animals and say animal
learning chimpanzees Project Nim for
people are interested highlights this
very hard fascinating and the society
aspect of that for example and the
replication of that tend to show the
same darkness of an ideal society and
what does that mean to manufacture one
yeah in the space where I find
fascinating probably with current
research I'm really interested I guess
like an armchair social psychologist
that I really read a lot in that space
that hearkens back to my dad and my
childhood which is
I think that there's a really
interesting place right now when people
focus in politics on the left and the
right that there's a bigger problem with
how people engage with uncertainty that
there needs to be a lot of work done on
the study of the tolerance that people
have for uncertainty and we've had the
pandemic we've had craziness we've had
the economy and I think it's really
interesting if you look at that as the
instead of left and right if you look at
that as North and South you have people
from both sides that need an absolute
answer when they're confronted with
something unusual and that need to fill
in the Gap that need to have an absolute
answer for something that they've seen
happen versus tolerance for uncertainty
I think could help inoculate people from
some of the problems that they're
running into there's going to be a
future where people think of as arms
race of Technology like when they think
about AI deep fakes but it's our arms
race of imaginations and tends to be
Thieves will beat you to it they'll be
innovating in that space pretty quickly
and they are right now with deep fakes
and other things and it's useful to see
how people are going to deal with having
something that looks very real you're
now in this very interesting time that
all the research historically for
mankind with deception tends to be on
spotting a lie spotting something that's
fake and I think we're on a cuss where
that's going to flip over and we're
going to have to try to spot the truth
and what does that mean in a future
terrifying yeah where you got to spot
the truth and how do you deal with that
and I think there needs to be a lot more
research on how we develop comfort with
uncertainty
how we authenticate all those types of
things there's there's books and
literature that's starting to come out
in that space and that's definitely I'm
leaning into that too because I feel
like since my job is distorting
perceptions and creating erroneous
sensemaking then I should really try to
lend a helping hand if I can so we may
come back to that but I want to First
return to something that we discussed
briefly but didn't really flesh out and
that is let's call it for lack of a
better term your style yeah before we
get to your style what is the
significance of any of that ring this
ring is made from a silver coin okay and
my magic used to be based around Sil
it's it's unusual if you talk to a
magician professional magicians very
pretty ring and for people who aren't
watching the video I've been watching
you play with it and manipulate it and
take it off and put it back on and I
would imagine given what you do that you
might choose your adornments with some
thought with a purpose so that's why I
ask all right everything has a purpose
there's lots of things that can be done
with this and actually when I
pickpocketed pendulette I met him the
first time and he's a big guy yeah 6'6
at least big guy yeah and he had heard
about historically among magicians
pickpockets are a kind
of a fake there's a lot of people that
say give me your wallet before the show
and then they steal it out and I didn't
have that background I came from a
different Lane and so he had heard from
a friend that I could really steal so he
put me on the spine from a bunch of
people first time I met him he he just
walked up to me he says so you can steal
stuff and I said yeah sometimes I can he
says then steal something from me he
held out his arms and I remember him
wearing like a Tommy Bahama shirt and
some shorts and he had block pen that
was clipped inside of his shirt pocket
and he said still something for me now I
said you know that's kind of like saying
be funny now I said he said yeah said
let me tell you about something that
happened to somebody one time if I steal
a watch from someone is one plus one you
say oh you're fast you got my watch I
didn't notice said but one time I was
talking to a guy and during the
conversation I stole his pen I took the
inside ink pen the refill of his pen out
put his pen back together put it back in
place and later I was asking him to sign
something and uh when he went to sign it
he couldn't he realized he couldn't he
went to write it down and he says okay
yeah are you going to steal something
from me I said can you draw a circle
around this ring for me and he pulled
out his P go do it and he stops he
stares at me and he realizes he's the
guy in the
story and he just sit back and go he
opened his pen and saw that the refill
wasn't there he goes [__] you and I said
now pen isn't that better than taking
your wallet and I threw his wallet on
the
table okay that's amazing now why is
that made of silver dollar silver
dollars in coin magic silver has a
unique property in that the way that it
feels on your skin the way it's soft the
way it can move and also the sound that
it mix specifically for slide of hand
silver works very well for slide of hand
as a memory of that even when I'm not
performing I had one converted into a
ring so they punched a hole and rolled
it into this
ring and it's a reminder to me of where
I came from for that very cool very
tension grabbing also which I would
imagine helps with things like what you
just described it can be used it can be
used as a level confidence I can talk to
you about and I'll show you something
with that actually because it does mean
a lot to me do you have anything in your
pockets right now I do yeah I have a
hotel Key I have some credit cards okay
great and I appreciate you let me know
where those are if I asked you right now
and this is something we could just just
fell for it gotcha [__] take this set
your pen down for a second and take the
my ring and put it in one of your hands
okay and now whether under the paper
behind your back put it in one of your
two hands so I can't see which hand it
would go in okay oh I'll do it behind my
back it's going to be a little tight
sorry about that yeah
right you got it I got so you put in one
of your hands now don't do the third
option which is putting in your pocket
no not going to do it okay bring both
your hands out now I'll try to guess
which hand it's right now it's in your
right hand correct it is in my right
hand can I see yeah okay do that again
okay okay bring it back out
yeah now it's in the left hand correct
is that right let me see yeah it is so
you try that with me okay so I all right
yeah I was trying to think like logic
through this like sort of like rock
paper scissors cuz I was like he would
expect me to probably go with the same
hand because I would maybe think it I
should switch hand I I sort of over
complicated for myself but which is
Princess Bride all over again yeah
Princess Bride all over again yeah so
try it with me and see what your process
is okay okay all
right right hand it was pretty fast
that's did you peek it or how did you
get it no I was looking at the the body
language okay yeah oh [__]
you're distracted I'll do it again I'll
do it again hold on all right so we're
doing a second time there you go left
hand left hand uh so it's a big move
because fixation would say stay there
you're now assuming that I took the same
pattern as you I switched the other hand
I could try to talk you out of that to
go back to the wrong choice but you made
the right choice I need you miss so I
can make my point hold on just one more
time all right one more time which hand
right hand would you like to change
no so this is not a mentalism effector
would be much better but I think but I
also have 50-50 chance so 5050 chance
yeah yeah yeah but but but I want you to
be able to make your point well so in
this that's a little Minicon with a
little ring and we often hear people
talk about biases so like confirmation
bias but when you embody in a real
interaction like this you would never
associate what we just did as
confirmation bias I think I have an
advantage over you also because you're
angled to me oh okay so you were able to
see kind of when my hand came out I
didn't see your hands but I think it's
easier for me to observe your body
language in a sense because you're
angled at me but that might be wrong I
don't know no it's an interesting
hypothesis
but I think that that's the interesting
thing that if it was never in my hand
and you were wrong every time you might
think I was cheating yes sure because
when we lose we're more Curious and when
we win we're less curious about why
we're winning right uh yeah
yeah okay so now you for those people
are watching now you have identical
Rings one in each okay got it a very
unique special ring that you start the
conversation on you found your own path
so in that that's little metaphor for a
con right that one they ring cuz that
whole story that you jumped into that
little rabbit hole with asking about the
ring is a great Baseline that now people
assume there's one and there's that
Baseline piece but to me that is that
greater question that when we're
succeeding we're often not curious why
we're having success and it's a very
unusual thing for us to say well let me
check out the other hand when you win
right when you win yeah yeah but that's
confirmation bias helpful to know what
that is and it's very easy you didn't
jump into the hole like most people do
most people will say well you know I I
played poker with my grandma since I was
four I'm really good at reading people
and they walk away with this confidence
and that's the con aspect of that but in
this right confidence it is confidence
you see me playing low status with that
I need you to miss in order for me to be
able to do that yeah but that kind of
thing everything is about helping people
get to that
yeah all right that was a great de demo
and that actually ties into the question
of can you elaborate on what makes your
style how is it different from what
people think
of as magic maybe what they've seen
growing up I'll give you an experience
one time where I had let's just see kind
of
Backstage one time I was performing for
a corporate event in Las Vegas and it's
similar to the one where I had the
broken watch piece but this is later in
my career and it was a new agents and I
was talking to her off to the side and
somebody I met a couple of the people
that were there one of the ladies who
ran the thing named Lisa so other people
but then this other guy came up
well-dressed guy and he said so I heard
you steal things is that right and I
said yeah something like that and he
says so steal something from me I said
I'm sorry what was what was your name he
says Jamal I said nice to meet you Jamal
before this let's go back that I walked
into this event thinking I don't want to
do anything I've done before exactly
there's some little ponents components
and you'll hear some things coming back
what I just talked about with pen but I
knew that I could figure out how to put
something inside of a bag of
M&M's and reseal it in real time without
anybody noticing and I thought what
could I do with that let's just find out
yeah yeah and that's where it started to
become a jazz so this interaction with
this guy Jamal when he came up he says
so you can steal something from me and I
said I I don't really know was your name
it goes Jamal I said how do you spell
that Jamal and he said J I said could
you write that down for me and he pulls
out his pen and goes to write it down
his pen wasn't working and as we've
heard before yeah and I said and up to
this point my stuttering the break of my
speech the break of my sight lines with
him has been very low status break of
your sight lines meaning eye contact
yeah I didn't keep straight eye contact
with him very much I asked him about his
suit that's really fancy it was all
those status and then everything just
changed then it's this thing I said
would this help y Jamal and it's
straight eye contact and it's the refill
to his ink pen and he had way
underestimated and stepped way too close
he realized suddenly and when that
moment happened to him you saw him
holding his pen with one hand and his
refill with the other and he was just
looking and he's stunned he's in this
cycle of trying to make that because the
only solution it could be is the one he
didn't want to accept right so he's
canceled out the truth so where is he
going to go from there yeah that I had
stolen it taken apart put it back
together and put it back on him couldn't
be that so what else could it be mhm
pausing Time time travel yeah so in that
now at that moment while he's in that
bewildered State I just said well at
least you didn't lose your money or your
wallet and when I did that I just
glanced down because I noticed he has
watch on his left wrist so he's probably
right-handed so he's probably going to
keep his wallet in his back right so I
just glanced back toward his back right
pocket and he jumped on that big he
reached in pulled out his wallet real
quick checked to see if he had
everything still in his wallet and I
laughed and I saw his attention shift
back to the pen and I pushed down his
hand I said you still have everything
and he he put it away and he says you've
got to do this to Lisa I said yeah great
to meet her I just looked over his
shoulder to where I thought Lisa might
be and he took off to go get Lisa comes
back and he shoves this lady towards me
in this agent and I'm dance monkey dance
yeah I have a I'm having well I'm there
to perform but no I know I know and I'm
talking to the agent I have a drink and
this is an important thing the drink
because it's a part of the style it's
not alcohol it's just water but I don't
need anything from him I'm not being inv
validated and a lot of performers will
try to spoon feed the audience but it's
letting them bring a thing to them
letting them have a reaction without you
needing to feed back off of it and
letting people have this experience for
themselves and so when he pushed the
lady up I I didn't quite look at at
first I said sorry it's nice to meet you
I looked over and I said what was your
name she goes Lisa and she hadn't quite
come close to me at all I said she said
what's happening I said sorry Lisa he
wants me to steal something from you she
say what I said do you like chocolate
she says chocolate I said yes there's
some chocolate in your purse she said
what she opens her purse and she finds a
bag of M&M's in her purse and he's
reacting very strongly to this and he's
watching this third party he think and
then she said how did those get on my
purse I said the same way Jamal's
driver's license got out of his wallet
now he's jumped back into the equation
he rips his water out and Ro says his
license is missing and he goes where in
the [__] is my driver's license and I
said it's in the chocolate as I take a
sip of my water and I just walk away so
I let them piece it together themselves
she tears over the M&M's and finds the
license in her thing okay so if we zoom
out then yes Amazing Story I mean I
would have to think 100% maybe
99.999% of people listening have never
experienced something like
this what are the ingredients you
mentioned some of them are there other
ingredients that you can call out
explicitly that are sort of the some of
the Hallmarks that differentiate yeah
and part of that that's quite different
in Magic is it tends to be that they'll
have a set of effects that are linked
together in that one I had a set of
skills that I could do by I hadn't piece
them together and I take advantage of
the movement it kind of like you would
if you were sparring in that way when he
leaned in forward I step back with my
left foot and I said it's nice to meet
you but at the same time as my right
hand comes up with the back of my hand I
kind of put my hand towards his chest as
he came in a little bit too close M my
left hand came up underneath the sight
line and slipped inside of his jacket
and took out his pen really quick and I
went down the line of my arm and into my
pocket so he couldn't see anything being
extracted and then I step back and then
I remove the pen take it apart and I
find another reason to come back in to
put it back there so outrageous that you
can do any of this it's amazing but it's
a strange thing and then each one of
those moments on the back side of that
is I didn't know what was going to
happen but what I saw is when his
attention locked to that pen and he was
spinning and he and you can think of
attention as being external internal or
internal inside your head or external
aware and you can think of as being
broad or narrow and on those aess it's
very useful of do I want him to be broad
external or do I want him to be internal
narrow and how do I flip somebody from
one to those to the other and I'm very
attuned to the doing that of moving
people between those four stages so that
was a big part there was to do that to
him and when he pulled that out and
thought he had the money I just copped
his driver's license out of it wallet
and let him put his wallet back but he
was already still thinking about the pen
so I could see he was thinking about the
pen so when I pushed down his hand I
just took the wallet out the problem is
his train of thought would go straight
back to it if I reveal oh I've got your
license yeah he would go straight to it
so I thought hm I guess I'm going to put
this license inside the M&M's let me see
how I can do that and as I'm thinking
about that he said well you should meet
Lisa I like what a great idea perfect
yes and I think she's the one I met
maybe there's more leases but let's see
where he goes and I said yeah it be nice
to meet her so he goes off and he takes
off to get Lisa I see another Lisa that
I have met so just in case I put it
inside the M&M's and then I walk over
while this other lady Lisa is talking to
these people I open her purse drop it in
there put it there and then I go back to
where I was he doesn't know this so it
was the right Lisa it was lucky for me
otherwise I'd have to be doing some
introductions yeah okay so I have to
ask what is it like for your wife to
have a fight or argument with you cuz it
could be seems like it could be a total
nightmare or she would have to become
such a
master in your craft to be able to mount
a
defense or that she would be like I have
some friends are a therapist and
sometimes their their kids will say stop
therapizing me Mom and they'll be like I
know what you're doing and they're like
oh so what what does that Dynamic look
like or is she like weapons and badge on
the table like take your tools put them
away I don't want any of your horeshit
like we need to have a talk it'd be
easier to have game on game off uh I
think we don't we we do use it in our
social interactions with each other as
well but she does it to so her career
path she became a mentalist she left her
career as a psychobiologist all right
this is this is non-trivial okay it's
huge and so she studied mentalism after
meeting Darren Brown she went deep down
that she started performing for
companies but she had the background to
science that I didn't have so she'
translate for me we had a daughter
together a number of years later and in
between those we had these unusual
experiences of going in very dangerous
places with different criminal groups to
learn about them together me and her on
these Adventures around the world in
different strange places why did you do
that like to learn what types of things
well it's easy to say that a magic
tricks comes from this book it's a
different thing to say but where did
this really come from where did this
idea really come from the a certain type
of pocket or a certain type of thing and
there were Legends of people doing
things in certain places there's these
group of women called the 40 elephants
that used to be in the UK and around
probably 1890 to 1940s they ran a
criminal group there and they could
steal a large amount of things by
altering their clothing and doing a
variation what's called boosters or
boosting that's my world an encyclopedia
of things like that and who's the people
are doing it now there's a research and
of footage showing up now that YouTube
is so pervasive with security cameras of
women doing things that are like that
where they're stealing a flat screen TV
32in flat screen TV and putting it
underneath their dress and walking
without changing their gate they're
taking 10 pound cases of beer or wine
and just making it vanish in their
clothing and walking without changing
their walk there's a very interesting
thing there that it becomes how is that
knowledge being transferred it probably
goes back to at least the one data point
I know the 40 elephants usually when I
interact with different cultures of
Thieves I track back through signals
that they use or language or terms that
they use and I try to track where they
learn from and we chased after that and
that's Ava and I did that a lot so to
your original question how do we as a
couple we both are fascinated by that
space we now have a kid and I'd say it's
more interesting probably for our kid we
don't teach her that it's bad to lie we
try talk to her that deception is social
lubricant it happens all the time around
us from the moment we put on makeup to
something else whether it be a defeat
for cancer by using decoy cells there's
all these things that have a reason but
about your intent and that's the big
thing so could you say more about that
because that that would be
very heretical to I'm sure some people
listening right wait a second no
deception badge yes right yeah no
exceptions yeah black and white that's
the dark side of the force so could you
say a bit more about how you teach your
child your children about deception
or if you want to tackle this a
different way you know is there a
pro-social or a positive use of
deception and a way to frame that for
people definitely the flag I fly under
now is I think that there's value in
learning about deception that one of the
reasons why we have critical thinking is
to counter deception and it's helpful
now when people say we need more
critical thinking to understand what was
the original reason for it why do we
need this reasoning process inside of a
communal culture we need to understand
the role of deception and there's been
chases in the history of the study of
the psych ology of deception of trying
to say well let's catch somebody and lie
or lying is all bad but it's not we use
lies and levels of disclosure in our
first dates it's funny if you hear me
now versus what my father's thinking
would have been as a child sorry my son
is advocating for deception but what I'm
advocating for is an awareness of what
deception is and expanding the horizons
of what people think it can be I'll give
you an example take the concepts that
are used here's a concept I'm going to
make someone think that they have acted
when they haven't that's a very generic
concept make them think that they have
acted on something taken an action when
they have it okay so I'll give you two
contexts for that if I as a pickpocket
steal from somebody in another country
and they don't not too familiar with the
language and I run away their response
will typically be to yell for police one
way of stopping that is to have a second
member of my team come up to them while
they're emotionally charged and to take
a police report and give them a ticket
and they think they have acted when they
haven't they have a piece mind that
they've taken some action and while
they're emotionally charged what do they
need to see maybe a clipboard a badge a
couple of things and I don't need to
show them much but that concept if you
can distill the concept of that how do I
fight
malaria it's female mosquitoes that bite
that transfer The Germ in
malaria but if I can release a hormone
to a female mosquito to make her think
that she has made it when she hasn't mhm
I make her think that she has behaved
taken an action when she hasn't taken
the action mhm you can stop the spread
of malaria it's the same concept so this
use of deception is really the broader
aspect how do we deceive a cell how do
we deal with Corona virus it can be used
in medicine it can be used in different
areas using truth to deceive that's a
very powerful thing it's the difference
between Mal information versus
disinformation is Mal information is the
use of true facts to deceive and
paltering is the name for it in business
of using it in advertising of using a
series of true statements to mislead can
you give an example I've never heard
that term before which paltering or in
yeah yeah paltering if I said it doesn't
have to be a business example but be an
example of using the truth to deceive if
I released a series of true statements
in a certain order you're going to
connect those and tell yourself a story
if you vet any of those true elements
they will show up to be true but because
they were delivered to you in a certain
order they'll create a belief and that's
the bigger thing how do I craft a belief
in you and that's been done a variety of
ways on both sides of the political
spectrum that we could say it's done in
advertising as well there's a great book
on propaganda by Eddie bernes where he
explored it with doing a study on the
most important meal of the day and it
was at that time I think funded by the
pork
industry and they found that breakfast
was the most important meal of the day
says so the All-American breakfast bacon
eggs and toast most important but that
wasn't part of the original study the
bacon and the eggs to become part of the
all- American breakfast but repackaging
that in there as well and a smaller
thing if I want to convey an implied
statement to you if I said Do You
Believe In
ESP sure yes well then I don't have
anything to do okay let's say let's go
no then I'm not sure where it's going so
if you say no uh I said some people
don't believe in ESP and some people
people don't believe we ever walked on
the moon right both those statements are
true but I imply a third statement that
now if you don't believe in ESP that
you're similar to the people with
conspiracy theorists who never believe
we walk in the moon right you're making
a sort of a false association
association by using true statements and
so it's also as a legality it's a lot
harder thing to grab on to and if I want
pull back one layer further slippery
it's slippery there's a lot of room for
deception in advertising and product
marketing also I mean there's so I
didn't know that term but there's a term
called puffery H which
is it's an implied structure or function
claim but you can't make structure
or function claims for instance with
dietary supplements or in shampoo
because then it would be governed by the
FDA would be and I'm simplifying this
but classified as a drug and therefore
you would have to go through all of
these different steps and studies and so
on to avoid that so puffery is the use
of words that have basically no meaning
whatsoever okay so if you sell if you
sell shampoo that is a hair
volumizer no agreed upon or legal
definition of volumize but it conjures
an image it does of a very distinct
effect absolutely it's total [__]
absolutely and when you have a label for
this and you get a few examples you
start to see it everywhere yeah it's all
over the place but in any case but
that's exactly to my point I I hope that
people expand Beyond just trying to
catch someone a lie because so many of
the things now that are impacting people
in major ways are going Beyond
fabrication they're going to
narratives that craft belief systems so
my push that I think is a nice way to
stay off the political phrase just to go
after how about I show you how these
things are traditionally done I'm going
to show you the anatomy of those I'm
going to try to familiarize you with
those that like I said deception
awareness what do you mean by
traditionally done the oh I see you're
saying okay we can talk about politics
or a modern incarnation of this type of
perceptual shaping but let's do it V the
40 elephants yeah because that my goal
if I attack a political piece in the
outcome of the behavior I'd like is I
would like for people to move more
Center yeah and I want there to be a
kind of diplomacy between people right
that's a very nature of politics so it
kind I get them off the extremes and I
believe that teaching them without
having to Target them with their current
beliefs to use these other metaphores
instead of a turtle I'm using cons and
other deception but to another point of
something more
I talked about change raising earlier
short changing somebody at cashier if I
want to be softer in that I could just
as a slight of hand artist I have the
ability to change a bill from one bill
to another right I can do that very
quickly but so do thieves M and if I go
to a cashier and I said uh can you give
me a $100 bill and I give you1 $10 bills
that doesn't raise a lot of Suspicion in
the way that a $100 bill would in the
other way where they vet that but now
you take those 10 tens you put them in
the register you hand them to me and I
take the 100 but I just look at the 100
and I say excuse me and when you look at
the 100 you see now there's a 10 there
instead of
100 what is my claim I just said excuse
me I didn't tell you that you gave me
the wrong thing I didn't make a bolster
of a claim I'm just allowing you to
assume a story write your own story and
if you assume the wrong story and think
you made a mistake and gave me a 10
instead of a 100 you're going to take
that back give me $1 and I made $90 mhm
but if you went the other way and you
were highly suspicious you're on top of
and you say what say could you give me
two fives so that allows me to go either
way because I have this 10 I can take
that Lan do you want can you give me two
fives and that's what it means by
equivocate so the equivocation of those
things is this ambiguity used to deceive
it can be taken in multiple directions
although you're kind of [__] on that
exchange right because you give the 10
it helps be able to have the
recording all right so I want to talk
for a second about books so when you
were younger there were these various
books you mentioned a few of them I
think one of them was JB Bobo's coin
magic yeah that was the book that Ben
Stone gave me yes right had a large
impact on your life your thinking and so
on are there books in later chapters
that have had an impact on you that come
to mind absolutely at specific points
there was
one where some people that I had worked
with started to say are you it was
almost an implication I was getting that
they thought it was psychic and I I
wasn't buying into that there was an
incident happened somebody had stolen
something from me at that show at Cesar
palace with hundreds of people and I had
a backpack and somebody got there and
stole out a set of special coins that I
had that were very sentimental to me
inste of a case that's a bummer probably
of no use to them yeah but it was both
emotional and significant to me and I
come back up I just changed in my street
clothes and I said hey with somebody in
my bag and the ticket ladies didn't know
I said what did they look like they said
yeah there's a guy back here I said old
young this darkhair Li hair and they
said not sure I said did he go in the
show route or did he go side door they
said side door said so he's in the
luminarium which is like a couple
hundred people in that space now and
they said yeah he's there I was like oh
man said Can you spot him if we go in
there and we go in when I go to look for
him I ended up finding this guy out of a
couple hundred people because they
helped you spot him no they didn't know
how to describe him I called my boss and
I said hey can we do an announcement
somebody stole my stuff can you do
announcement that we know that they
stole it he says no I said all right so
then I went back in changing my uniform
for the the show and I went through
everybody's Pockets I started going
through assessing and profiling a few
hundred people and I found the guy and
it was just you eliminating different
people grandpa's not going to do this
this guy guy's family he's not going to
take that chance this and so I narrowed
down a couples and other things and then
I see this guy and he's with another
girl and I went up to him and I said hey
man what's your name and he goes slick
and I and he called himself I mean
that's not the thing but as I went by he
was wearing like jogging pants and he
only had something in his front left
pocket so I tapped the thing not tap tap
but enough for me to know what it was it
was my case so then I stole it back from
him without I'm knowing and I went and
told my boss hey I found this guy can
you call security and he said he's
laughing and he's just like no you took
the evidence he said but how can you
find this guy he say what and he's
telling everybody else but at that time
back to your book's question I I always
get on tangents I really wanted to
understand what was happening there was
like is NLP is this everybody says NLP
is that what this is and it wasn't that
but it was what you were doing or what
he was doing people were thinking about
what I was doing as far as and I didn't
believe it was I had super skills you
were trying to deconstruct what you
yourself and I pushing at the science
and I was really and so I found out
about Robert chalini and his book on
influence and different studies on the
history of persuasion I started ordering
textbooks from universities and really
going into that but then now my areas of
Interest the nice thing is I'm friends
with a lot of the authors that I know so
Dan Simons just wrote a book called
Nobody's Fool that is going specifically
after a problem that I'm very interested
in which is if we posit this idea that
we need more critical thinking we really
need to Define what critical thinking is
because critical thinking I think is
being used as a filler term to fill in
the blank whenever we got a problem for
reasoning and I think it needs to be
more specific than that to solve the
problem what Behavior do we want to
change do we want people to have an
alternate
hypothesis to question their hypothesis
is when is that the case and when is
that conspiracy theory and it now
becomes the fixation on beliefs and when
should we question what we think we know
and that's a very specific thing so a
lot of the things I'm reading right now
are how beliefs are constructed when
should we question what we think we know
and how often do we update our belief
systems is there firmware that needs to
be updated and how do we go about doing
that I'm trying to find what my role is
in trying to help with that outside of
technical Magic
books and I'm using magic broadly could
be any facet of that type of performance
what books have you reread that come to
mind I read quite a bit when I'm
hovering around right now I I say that
rereading it but I'm going to be soft on
the title I think it's called how minds
are changed it's an important book that
goes into the impact of deep canvasing
and is it possible to change someone's
mind in a conversation with any lasting
results and what is the process of doing
that and that's different than a
traditional magic book it's and also
when should you and why should you it
poses the idea of questioning your own
beliefs and how you arrived at those and
how necessary it is for you to update
yours and I go back to that quite a bit
there's a book called the person and the
situation I think it's a nisbit we can
get all the specific put I do suffer
from that when I buy a book I think I'm
going to buy the time read it but I do
have several that I go back to
repeatedly it tends to be that they are
for specific functions of the things
that are driving me in life a friend of
mine wrote a book called deception in
digital age and he was with the FBI his
name is Cameron ma it's a fascinating
book in that space that I go into a
lot does whism mob hold any special
place in your heart or mind and what is
wi yeah so okay if you go to books as a
to the spirit of your question which is
what I should have listened to uh I
don't blame you for not listening to my
spirit it's an acquired taste no there's
probably so Bubba's coin magic right and
then there was the fitsy books that Ben
Stone tricked me into reading uh that
guy huh they still reverber IED because
magic the a study of misdirection and
then wiiz mob wiiz mob was that it was
this ju's position that there was a
Professor David Mau who was studying the
language of Thieves and not just he
wrote two books he wrote The American
confidence man which later became big
conon and it was one chapter of that was
turned into the movie Sting and that
influenced a lot of other parts of that
book were turned into elements for other
movies The Arc and heist movies and I
was very interested in because he was a
a linguist Professor who was studying
the language of Thieves and whs MOB was
a specific type of theft and it's not
just a pickpocket on the
street the name of whiz mob is this idea
that there are thieves that travel and
they don't just work as a team but there
are some thieves that have learned all
the roles in a team they could shift
between those roles so they didn't need
the team anymore and they were called
cannons this term came back from the UK
a long time ago and Mau was tracing that
back and he noticed that it was showing
up in Chicago and other places that
cannons were around but he started to
meet some people that were coming into
to Louisville Kentucky for I guess the
Kentucky Derby for this event and he
found that there were groups of cannons
that would find each other
internationally and play as bigger teams
and they were fascinating because it was
hard for surveillance to catch them
because they could change their
composition as a team change their
tactics and they had very different
skill levels and that lit a fire for me
to try to find a cannon to try to find
Wiis mob and The New Yorker article that
is all about that of me finding my first
cannon and then a year ago when I moved
to Washington DC another Canon reached
out to me by email and it said hey we
have similar interest with Ma's work I'm
one of the original WIS mom and I said
what I said well that's an easy thing to
vet and I said so it's in writing right
so I got to vet this guy out and he
talked about when he was 14 years old
and he was a 6'4 black man coming to at
that time it was very hard to get some
in space so he had to invent whole new
approaches to stealing also what racism
meant in that kind of community he was
writing a book about that huh and he
wanted to get together with me he lives
in the DC area and uh we haven't still
haven't got together so sometime if you
want to get together with the two of us
yeah I'm been yeah but that is the
driver that's where I used to spend a
lot of my time and the that book Ma's
book taught me to be a student of these
Arcane disciplines let's see what I
could learn so question on Arcane
discipline as it applies to the team
roles so people may be familiar with the
different positions on an American
football team or basketball team right
probably are not familiar with the
different roles that a Canon could take
so what does a team of Thieves look like
or at least what are some of the
fundamental roles I think a lot of
people don't know the structure of a
pickpocket team they tend to know
football basketball baseball very
intimately and very impassioned but for
a pickpocket team it tends to be
different there are their intention not
to be seen it is yes and there's names
for them historically the wire the stick
the shade the stall and they all have
functions in what people would think is
oh that's just a diversion but it's more
than that and as you move from country
to Country there's different approaches
of how people steal in one country
versus another and it tends to be that
you see them move like a school of fish
through a crowd so if somebody's in an
event and they've locked onto a Target
as that Target moves through whether
it's a casino or an event you'll see the
thieves move with as a Circ kind of a a
school of fish and the roles with that
the wire is kind of embodied in a
character from a movie called Harry
never holds and it was about a
pickpocket that would steal from people
and he would hand off his stuff if
anybody rolled him up he's the
quarterback they don't want to catch the
quarterback because he's the most
valuable player that function as a
metaphor so how would he pass who would
he pass to and the other roles in the
team team become the Stalls or the
sticks which they set up a frame they
stop somebody's elbow from moving
backwards and grabbing hold of the
thief's hand they might open a newspaper
they might look at a book if it's on a
subway but they're going to be
underneath the edge of an elbow so a
hand can't get back so that's what I
mean like setting a frame on running
interference yeah so they came and move
back that then there's the shade the
shades kind of counter surveillance
they're looking to identify undercover
law
enforcement as they scope through a
crowd they're very good at identifying
what they look like and also where the
cameras are and there's a steer who
identifies the good targets pause for
one second so the shade is that a a
pregame activity or is that done real
time how do they alert people to an
issue well that's often an indicator of
who they are too like a shade might use
a physical
indicator sometimes as different groups
go they used to use nexttel phones so
I've seen that happen at a mall when I
visited DC a number of years ago I've
seen it happen different ways in Japan
with like kissing noises in Naples they
do whistles it's different sounds
Colombian diversion teams will use like
a finger up the back of the neck which
indicates that we have surveillance and
split and they'll do probe testing where
maybe as somebody's going in to do a
steel if they sense they've got heat
from a surveillance they might drop
their sight line towards a lady's purse
mhm and if someone bounces off their
sideline and tracks to that they know
they've got Heat they give a signal to
their team to dissipate okay so we
stopped the shade I interrupted so what
came after shade steer a steer is
somebody who qualifies the mark and
these are right out of wisma but as I
started meeting different teams it's
been fascinating to find people on the
street that still use variations of
these terms because that means somehow
they learned those from someone so what
does the steer do they qualify the mark
they do a testing bite and they're like
well think about the cost risk
Association of if we're going to going
to make a play on someone we might go to
prison for it we need to qualify the
more want to make sure the juice is
ripped the squee so how do you
qualify it's changed now with phones but
what I mean if you have earbuds or any
kind of cord going down to a device I
now know where it is and I can qualify
that and so for a lot of Eastern
European teams and in England and other
places they just know that you're going
to have a phone so more people become
targets just for their phones because
they know how to fence those and run
those in the market clever things of
what they can do with a phone now they
can run it three whole bank accounts
really quick they can access your bank
account Visa your phone yeah and I don't
know exactly this play because it's not
like a zero day major hack not like
sponsored State hack they they do have
some way of getting into your phone
pretty quick and I've seen that over the
last three years take a surgence of
steing at a nightclub it could be as
simple as pointing it back at you get
your facial recognition but they're some
kind of automation that they're running
to be able to run through all your
accounts through your passwords shut you
out set up dual Factor authentification
lock you out of everything and just take
you virtually yeah so that's a whole
different thing but back in the day once
upon a time when the steers would go
they'd be more interested in when you go
to an ATM or a bank and you you qualify
they call it peeking the Poke seeing
what what money is inside the wallet and
when they would they had names for all
these things the U pit the kick the
bridge the fob Uptown downtown for
different pockets they all had names and
they could use them around each other it
was a very rich language that has some
of its permeated into our culture it's a
fascinating place the
steer I think for me when I'm looking
for a team I often look for the steer
the steer of the shade if I'm in a crowd
I'm looking for their Scout because the
Scout's moving Sidelines I look at for
people that are either targets or
they're law enforcement and I can
identify those and if I can identify
them somebody else is looking at them so
then I just track Sidelines through the
crowd to see who's looking at them and
then I'm going to look for their signals
and I can start to identify the group
and then I can start to look at how
they're doing there so from a from a
defensive
standpoint someone's going on a road
trip they're going to be going through
all sorts of countries and they're going
to be in crowded environments surrounded
by lots of people chances are there's
going to
be if not solo operators teams in these
environments right let's say it's
festivals and so on where certainly
teams are at work right much like the
Kentucky Derby right or you go to
Carnival you can your ass are going to
be some pros there mhm what would your
advice be to someone who doesn't want to
get their stuff taken I guess I would
imagine their's just don't carry
anything you don't need to carry there's
other preventive measures I mean you
hear about money belts and this that and
the other thing what are your thoughts
just like self-defense it's a mindset
first okay and over the last 30 years I
guess that I've been doing this kind of
crazy three decades I've
seen Society
lower their situational awareness and
increase their overconfidence oh it's
crazy and it's a Jos between that it's
the pandemic of the Dunning ker effect
it's this level of unconscious
incompetence or this illusion of
invulnerability and there's articles
saying that pickpockets don't really
exist anymore that that's gone down I
disagree and pickpockets aren't the only
problem like I just talked about the
hacking element of this deep fakes is a
whole new thing I mean a recent thing
that's just gone a case with
impersonating you might have seen this
on a ransom case where they implied that
they ransomed a daughter and this is
okay so they they used a deep fake to
quote unquote prove that they had
kidnapped someone the audio they had the
audio of a daughter talking to a mother
screaming that she's been kidnapped and
I mean that's going to drive anybody to
take the behavior right away so they
were able to extract The Ransom mhm I
believe so I know that's being
prosecuted though right now and I think
it's one of the early lessons there's
also weaponized as far as in the
military right now
there was some impersonated the mayor of
keev within the last 3 months that was
speaking to other Mayors in Europe and
it was russian-based but they were on a
real-time live Zoom call while they were
talking to these people and doing a
real-time live deep fake on a zoom call
and then about a few minutes in there
was some kind of glitch or longer than
that they got enough information there
was a glitch and then they called back
to speak to the mayor keev and they said
he hasn't been on a call and so there's
a future there that's coming that
int so a lot of these Concepts where I
mention them from pickpocketing and
things that's why I notic I didn't go to
just getting a better money belt yeah I
went to the importance for Concepts
because the overconfidence will work
against people oh yeah you see people in
any major city we're sitting in New York
City right now the number of people I
have seen see a go signal and walk
across the street with earbuds in
looking at their phones not checking
either direction yeah in this city
Y is unbelievable I mean hundreds of
them I've seen hundreds two times when
I've been to Japan the first time I went
there there was this kind of connection
of everybody around and then the second
time couple decades later went back the
latching in of the smart phones and it
really does become this kind of not
narcissism but this kind of egocentric
ISM of their through their virtual world
they're exploring out there and while
they're plugged into that like the
Matrix I guess you'd say their physical
body becomes vulnerable and so as a
predator mindset of looking at people
like that there used to be a term among
Thieves called the Griff sense and they
felt that the Griff sense was more
important than technique the ability to
extract that from someone and be able to
know where their attention was how much
they're investing their attention on a
thing now it becomes more salience when
somebody's holding their phone and you
can see where their attention is and you
can see what they're doing so I don't
want to beat a dead horse here but I am
curious let's just say you've tried to
identify the minimum of the essentials
that you want to have on you right you
got you got a safe at the hotel not
saying that's automatically safe by the
way but for argument sake you've tried
to leave as much behind as possible you
have no cash you're like I'll try to use
Apple pay you got your phone where
should you put it on your body like are
some targets I would imagine some are
harder than others yeah they are you're
inside jacket pocket inside jacket
pocket used to think that that was the
hardest pocket to steal from because
they were caught kissing the dog um that
was the old term kissing the dog meant
that I would have to see the Mark's face
mhm with most other extractions you
wouldn't get to see me my team would
lock you up I would work in a a blind
spot angle and I would do an extraction
that way but if I had to steal from
inside your jacket pocket I've come up
with a few ways to extract that without
you happen to see my face per
se I could show you maybe some of that a
little bit headbutting the dog yes
buting the dog make sure they don't
remember so inside jacket pocket is a
spot I think it's more of when you take
things out to make a payment it's useful
to leave something there I thing that
often beats security is what they call
satisfaction of search where they're
looking for a thing an anomaly they find
something that satisfies that and they
stop looking you can reverse that and
use that for thieves give them something
to find if you're going to go make a
purchase out somewhere quarantine a
portion of your money any valuables that
you have sentimental or other things
don't wear them publicly and those if
you're moving into any kind of isolated
spot cuz not just pickbox it's going to
for be getting mugged too M and you can
hide them in plain sight so for example
what is your EDC what are the things you
carry with you now more and more people
are carrying everyday carry yeah EDC
everyday carry and definitely a
pickpockets library right your water
bottle a coffee cup those things if I
take things that are value sentimental
value an improvised safe could be a
coffee cup I put these items inside of a
coffee coffee cup put a lid on it and
now even if you rob me strip me taser me
and strip me down you probably won't
search in that coffee cup that's the
mindset that I'm talking about right so
the idea of treating the unimportant as
important and the important as
unimportant if you want to simplify it
and I think you can take that to your
hotel room are you going to buy some
kind of stash concealment that looks
like after shave or you're going to do
those things instead of leave something
there in the safe because you need to
satiate their curiosity you need to give
the dog a bone to find you need to as
herb Simon in behavioral economics he
would call it satisficing you need to
something that satisfies your
curiosity I'm glad I asked thank you
what is the illusion of knowledge
project so we have a new company that
we're trying to
create and I've kind of tiptoed into
that as we've been speaking about
because it's a it's a soft business
model we're trying to still shape of
what the market is for that but we think
it's important to point the finger
at the problem that we see on the
horizon the benefit is I have amazing
network of people that I've learned from
that used to be Thieves but now it's
security Specialists and other ones and
just specialists around the world that
are incredible experts in these areas
and I I was saying my background is in
entertainment we did some TV Works
different things can we repackage shows
whether it's TV or live experience or
content that can help people engage with
things that they might not think are
important their data their other things
can you reverse a rumor escape and make
it a heist and while people are trying
to break into a thing they learn about
their personal data these kind of
examples that's a fun idea yeah probably
is now stolen that I've said it out loud
we could we could add in a bunch of
bleeps if you like yeah I know it's
leave it in there it's just karma for me
doing all the things I've done but the
it's the kind of things that give you
those ideas so we did a project along
that it was a video project called the
illusion of knowledge and it's this
Daniel bson quote that the enemy of
knowledge is not ignorance it's the
illusion of knowledge
and that marries so well with my
background growing up around cons MH and
since my job has always been instilling
confidence not just the extraction of
personal items from a person it's
getting people to make other decisions
and as I learn about that I think it's
very important for people understand
that we are all puppets that we all have
strengths and it's a benefit for people
to know that about themselves instead of
saying but I'm not a puppet and realize
that they do have a string and what does
it mean for somebody to pull that string
and that awareness of how what it looks
like in different ways that those
strings can be pulled I think can help
bring people so that the flags go up so
we're creating this project the lusion
knowledge project to kind of highlight
some of that where can people find that
or can they not yet find it they can't
find it yet it's there's a trailer
that's we have this website called
equivoke and equivoke is
eqi v k or they can go to my website
it's easy my website is I steal stuff
and it's easier for people to remember
while they're driving but if you go to
that there will be a link to equivoke
there's a link to those things explore
and poke around I don't have much
content out there that I put as products
because right now I'm at a phase where I
have two kids I have one that's 30 one
that's six and I want to try to do the
thing that I can to change the world in
the way that I can and so a lot of these
are Legacy type things that build it
first build business model later which
is probably the best approach but it's
something that I'm doing right now you
know it may not always be the most fail
safe approach but it is I think the
approach that I see align
with intention and integrity very often
in people who are and I mean this in the
most complimentary sense possible high
level Craftsmen or crafts
women and it's it's not impossible to do
it can be difficult to do yeah but I
don't think it's an incorrect approach
does that make sense yeah because
because you can
conversely and look I invest in a lot
of or I have historically invested in a
lot of startups and early stage
companies and so on and it can be
incredibly profitable to start with a
model and then figure out what fits
around that yeah however when you have a
craft and when you have
the the refined perception and ability
to operate in the world that you have
that you can expand into these different
domains I I think that approach makes a
lot of sense I I really do because you
can corrupt the sincerity of the
knowledge you've accumulated by force
fitting it into a model into a model
yeah yeah well said I don't know if the
right metaphor of spoken Hub but it is a
little bit like that that I have
different ways I've been able to make a
very good living through whether it's
speaking or doing workshops or doing
training or creating things to teach
security and as I'm doing those since I
got my
boxes checked I felt okay let's be
exploratory let's what else can I use
this thing that I have this network that
I have and instead can it be something
that is using the fun part of where I
came from so I have to ask because this
is just my brain won't let it go yeah so
the 40 elephants I just love this name
are there other historical figures
or bands of Merry pranksters criminals
who have particularly memorable names or
stories for you like like if you had to
put together your League of Legends is
there a short list I've Had The Good
Fortune of meeting a lot of interesting
characters but there's some that I've
spent time with and there's some that
I've just read
about in the space of like famous
thieves or con artists there is the
unsinkable Titanic Thompson who Titanic
Thompson yep his the nickname was Tai
from those who knew him well there's
books been written about him I think
people have talked about doing movies
over the years but supposedly he would
advertise he was coming to a town
because he gambled on everything and
people were drawn to that he was a
proposition bet Hustler but he had super
skills heired proposition bet Hustler
meaning he bet on things that he would
just win he had special set of skills or
support staff covert support staff that
allowed him to make outrageous bets on
weird things can you think of an example
yeah one he would bet just first on like
golf he's very good at golf and he would
play somebody and he' be beating them
and he says listen I'll give you a
handicap I'll play with left-handed and
then he would beat him again and they
didn't realize that he was left-handed
but he's that good that he could beat
people right-handed back to Princess
Bride again yeah and so he definitely
could switch the hands he was very
famous for being able to throw things
accurately inside of cups from a
distance other things he could throw a
card from a long ways away through a
window and being above a pool hall was
one story where he would be trying to
toss that hat missing occasionally and
side bets on a poker game and he says
I'll bet a grand that I can toss a card
through that window all the way down
where the window is and sobody take the
BET and throw a card through and then
they close down the window he gets a
second bet he says listen I'm going to
throw it through the window it's going
to come back and it's going to stick to
the outside the window what no just
silly and it would and you see those in
the literature about like no that's like
magic territory yeah and then somebody
be eating pretzels and he says and the
pretzel I'm going to take that pretzel
and throw it over that story building
over there or that Walnut and they said
no that can't and he would and he' throw
a pretzel over a walnut so he seemed
like some kind of Robin hoods superhero
but there's great books on him the
unsinkable Titanic Thompson I have the
Good Fortune of knowing the last
surviving member of his team that was
the guy who was down below in the pool
hall with a fan and rubber cement who
painted the
window but he would do amazing things to
layer these very intricate cons besides
that so there's a handful of those guys
the unsinkable Titanic time
Thompson Joseph wheel the yellow kid
come Victor lustig he's a guy who sold
the Eiffel Tower twice and it's amazing
how do you sell the Eiffel Tower and it
is a beautiful con of you took advantage
of the time when the Eiffel Tower was
not had the significant value that it
did it was after World's Fair and it
might need to be turned into scrap so he
put out bid as a city official to be
able to look for somebody who could tear
it down and then as different
contractors bid on it he found a guy who
really needed the job and and meanwhile
the wife of the guy says I think there's
a rat I smell something there's
something up here and he had the
beautiful turn in a con which he
recognized at the wife had that
suspicion and he answered unique way he
just said listen I'm I got to make
something on this if you guys really
want this deal I'm going to need a cut
so they decided okay hey that's the rat
that's the thing he he is suspicious
he's a city official who needs a cut
instead it's a whole fake so not only
did he get the money he was getting he
also get the extra money as well oh man
so there's a all these guys all these
interesting lessons of these guys and
but I had a personal best friend for 17
years who Rod The Hop say again Rod the
hop The Hop yep and he is significant if
people have ever watched like Oceans 11
and they wondered well I wonder if
there's a real ocean there's a couple of
guys that Ocean's character would
probably be attributed to but Rod would
be on that short list among Thieves at
least and he was a legend among Thieves
and people didn't know what he looked
like generally because of the nature of
the work but he played a lot of
different styles he was a card Hustler
card cheet but there's like a southern
style a gardinia
style these different styles are playing
long and short games they're using
devices that shoot out your sleeve and
grab things called the joint or keper
hold out he was very good at a lot of
those things I met him when I first
moved into Vegas he was sitting off in a
corner I said it was a thing where some
magicians were in he was off the side of
that and he was playing with plastic
cards and he was shuffling them at the
table and not in a way that magicians
handle cards MH and he had an edge that
was a little bit more felt like family
to me and I saddled up to him talked to
him a little bit so not the way that
magicians handle cards in the sense that
you recognize more of like a working
card mechanic yeah cuz mechanics can't
have flourish they can't pick up the
deck off the table they don't Shuffle in
the same way that they do all their slce
have to be done within the constraints
of what the casinos have manifest right
so it would look very mundane
on the surface but there's a lot going
on there and also plastic cards
magicians would never want to use
plastic cards but poker players would so
when I began talking to him we kind of
hit up a friendship and talked a little
bit and as he learned more about my past
and I was going through a divorce at the
time too I was around 21 he knew I
needed some money and he said hey you
want to come play with my team and they
were hitting casinos or at least side
spots kind of periphery casinos or gas
stations and hitting slot machines and
things and it could cheat a slot machine
and make it pay out a bonus but he
needed watch guards he needed me to
learn a Cody's system and stuff and I
said sorry man I've grown up around some
things like this and there's this line
that I know once I step across the line
I'll always move it so I can't man but I
really appreciate it he says well how
about all these Magic books what are you
trying to what are you going to do with
those I said I don't know I guess I'm G
to have to sell them to get this thing
for the divorce and he said well I'll
buy those from you so he bought all my
magic books from me and one of his team
turned on him and he end up getting
arrested right after that and he sent I
got this box of books back with this
kind of little note as a friend just
saying I knew you wouldn't take the
money unless I did this and gave me all
my books back so later when he got out
of prison I said I'm doing some new
stuff now and I need some friends you
want to be a friend and I asked him to
join our team great
line so he joined the team and we had
about a dozen guys Kevin mitnick a
famous hacker was one of those guys they
of deception yeah and he was a dear
friend who just recently passed away oh
I didn't know that sorry saw him right
before he got sick last year with cancer
but very dear friends I've learned so
much from but rod used to do Heist on
casinos mittnik had all of his Legends
it's a story for another time but it's
I've been influenced by amazing guys in
that way that I've learned about so what
did the team do what was he doing on the
team uh so that was a definitely I can
clarify a bad business model so that was
whis mob and Incorporated inspired by
the book you mentioned whs Mom and the
idea was that we would Team guys
together and send them out for as a
speaking Agency for security maybe team
him with their counterparts and law
enforcement mnik already had that game
going he was doing full penetration
testing so he just hung out with us as a
subject matter expert like when it was
beneficial to learn what are covert
communication systems that pickpockets
use versus C use versus a second story
hacker or guys that would break into a
place like a cat burglar functionally so
all those kind of guys we had kind of in
our Cadre and they all had different
ways of approaching those things so it
was valuable also him and pulling and
tugging at Social Engineering which I
considered very similar to an evolution
of con and so I he had me come in and
speak at Defcon I and at his company no
before later but we learned from each
other in those worlds
wow well we've covered a lot of ground
here is there anything that we haven't
covered that you'd like to cover is
there anything you'd like to share with
the audience
ask of my audience anything at all
before we start
to wh to a close my daughter's six but
when she was around three she was
learning a lot of new words that I don't
say and you try to choose what's a good
word and a bad word and how often if you
use the word no too much do they become
numb to him so maybe use other words
besides no and I was always interested
in how different experts do parenting
and what that might be and but there was
a word she asked me what does boring
mean without really think about too much
I said it's a word that's not a bad word
but it's a word I don't use really
because I I don't really have it I don't
I've never been
bored but part of it is because boring
means that your imagination is broken so
you got to find a way to do it you got
to find something to do and you got to
use your imagination better and I didn't
realize what that would do but now I
have a kid who's never said that they're
bored and that's a huge thing that's
huge what an advantage what happens when
we just change a word M what does it do
to a behavior so in all the long drivve
she's taken with us across the country
she's never said I'm bored she knows
what it means she hears her friend say
it and she doesn't think of my dad tells
me not to say it because I I told her
you can say it but she chooses not to
and it's a thing that I'm obviously
proud of her about that but it's also to
me such a valuable thing of the state of
being bored is where creative epiphanies
often happen but what if we just remove
that word and think of it in a different
way and we think about it as
when when she is in that state she say I
need some help I need to think of
something to do and she's just doing
that and I said well there's so many
things and you only got so much time
where do we want to start and I said
should we go this way or that way or
what and it becomes a different thing I
said do you want to do something that
you want me to help you generate come up
with some ideas or she says no I just
want to think for a little while so
she'll just look out the window and
think and so it's a fascinating thing to
look at how long her attention span is
compared to a lot of her friends do you
think that that has helped her despite
not having I
assume not having had the force Gump
races
mhm to become a better Watcher in the
same way that you became a good Watcher
I think so I think that is one of the
contributors I think also I'm a big
proponent of I used to call it covert
learning strategies of the Miyagi aspect
of I'm going to do covert learning to
repackage the hard lessons as something
else oh you want to learn how to
levitate a coin I think it's in uh
exactly three books absolutely oh you
only read volume one I think it's in two
or three and there's two things because
if somebody has a big ego and they don't
think that they need to learn something
or you have learned helplessness where
people don't think it's possible for
them to learn it so what if I hide that
another pro-social application of
deception maybe I can use that to help
them learn a thing they thought was
irrelevant and secretly I've taught
possible yes and now by the way you can
do it and so I'm really interested in
that space and we do that to her all the
time like trying to teach her a memory
system can of repackage as a series of
other things that now this little tour
that we took was secretly a mind Palace
and now she learns how to do that so
what are the different ways that you can
package Lear Trojan Horse
absolutely Apollo what a gift what an
incredibly fun conversation I think we
may stand up and try to do some things
so for people who are interested in some
more visual you can go to Tim Ferris on
YouTube and we will hopefully post some
goodies there for you where are the best
places for people to find you online I'm
on Facebook although there seems to be
like five or six of me that isn't me but
as imposters do sort of appropriate see
so I haven't canceled them out but
there's one me on Facebook I'm on
Instagram not very active but I'll
probably be more I haven't engaged with
the new version of Twitter I haven't
fully jumped onto the next can't bring
myself to say Tik Tok I'm not coming
close to just my security mind won't let
me even touch it yeah don't do it but on
uh Twitter at Apollo Robbins yeah so
pretty much at Apollo Robbins across the
board there are a lot of my audience
very very interesting folks are on
Twitter so it's worthwhile mentioning
that just because that might be fun to
see yeah how things come out of the
woodwork and then as far as websites go
y best website or website
well they funnel through the same thing
of Apollo robbins.com or IAL stuff.com
IAL stuff they'll take you to the same
place but this other new one that is
going to be a separate thing is equivoke
and that one will be probably a
combination of an entertainment blog
with other video content and other
things where we're going to be try to
point to tools that are important in
this space there's a a guy that I think
is
amazing that studies deception Simon
Henderson he's from the UK he's probably
one the him Anthony panis my wife Ava do
all them as a collective will be doing
interviews videos and other things for
those guys so if you want to come play
in the space learn a little bit about
cons we won't attack your political
beliefs but we will attack what you
believe what a great place to end Apollo
thank you for such an
incredibly not just entertaining but
educating and invigorating conversation
I'm so glad that you made the time and
for people listening in you can do more
than you may believe you were capable of
doing so Paulo and I and hopefully you
will seek to prove this out and we'll
put links in the show notes as always to
everything we talked about at tim. blp
podcast and as usual I'll say it again
until next time please be a bit Kinder
than is necessary not only to others but
also to yourself and thanks for tuning
in